TO ORDER.
BEFORE WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE ONE I
FIGURED WE GET STARTED WITH THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING COMPONENTS
A WELCOME THE SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES IN WATER.
WE'RE GONNA START THIS MORNING
WITH A A BRIEF INFORMATIONAL.
NOTE FROM ROSS BROWN AT THE LA --
YOU TALK ABOUT FINANCING FOR
CLIMATE RESILIENCY.
AND THAT SORT OF LEAD UP TO OUR
FIRST ITEM TODAY OF THE AGENDA
SB.
FORTY FIVE I DON'T KNOW IF LA --
IS IN THE HOUSE YES WELCOME --
AND THE YEAH LET'S LET'S GET
STARTED -- WELCOME I THANK YOU A
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
SENATORS MY NAME'S JACKIE BRIAN
BROWN RUSSIA IN MY COLLEAGUES
YEAH ROSSI LE FROST AT ALL OKAY --
I WANT TO HOG ALL THE GLORY
TODAY PLEASE DO -- AGAIN MY
NAME'S BRIAN BROWN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO COME IN AND
DO A SHORT PRESENTATION FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
COULD PROVIDE SOME BACKGROUND
AND CONTEXT THE DELIBERATE FOR
SB -- FORTY FIVE BASED ON THE
REQUEST THE HANDOUT THAT WE
PREPARE WICH I BELIEVE ALL THE
MEMBERS ALREADY HAVE THERE ARE
SOME.
ADDITIONAL COPIES FOR THE PUBLIC
AND IT'S ON OUR WEBSITE AS WELL
BUT REALLY THE HANDOUT CONSIST
OF OF THREE PARTS ONE ALL TALK
VERY BRIEFLY ABOUT.
WHAT THE CLIMATE SCIENTISTS ARE
TELLING US ABOUT THE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL ECONOMIC AND FISCAL
AFFECTS?
IN THE STATE -- SECOND I'LL TALK
A LITTLE BIT JUST GENERALLY
ABOUT HOW STATE BONDS WORK --
WHAT THE COSTS ARE TO THE STATE
AS WELL MAKE SOME COMMENTS ABOUT --
SORT OF SOME TYPICAL LA --
COMMENTS ABOUT -- GOOD BOND
PRACTICES AND ORPHALI WE HELPFUL
AND THEN LASTLY PER YOUR REQUEST --
ALL BE TO SPENDING A FEW MINUTES
TALKING ABOUT WHAT ARE OTHER
ALTERNATIVE FUNDING MECHANISM
STATE LOCAL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CAN USE THE FINANCE CLIMB OUT
CLIMATE ADAPTATION ACTIVITIES.
ON BEFORE I BEGIN I SHOULD JUST
PREFACE THIS WITH A NOTE THAT
OUR OFFICE DOES NOT TAKE A
POSITION ON BILLS SO MY COMMENTS
ARE MEANT TO BE.
CONTACT BACKGROUND INFORMATION
AS YOU DELIBERATE SB FORTY FIVE
BUT WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON
THE BILL ITSELF.
ALL RIGHT THAT WITH THAT IF YOU
TURN TO PAGE ONE OF YOUR HAND
OUT.
AN ISSUE I'M SURE THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE ARE ALREADY VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THAT WHAT IS THE
CLIENT CLIMATE.
SCIENCE TELLING US ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE IN CALIFORNIA AND YOU CAN
SEE HERE ON THE FIRST TWO PAGES
A RANGE OF A FAX I'M GOING TO
EACH ONE BUT WE EXPECT TO SEE
SEA LEVEL RISE ALONG THE COAST.
INLAND FLOODING.
INCREASES IN TEMPERATURE BOTH
OVERALL AVERAGE TEMPERATURES AS
WELL AS HIGH HEAT EVENTS.
WE EXPECT TO SEE MORE AND MORE
SEVERE DROUGHTS IN THE FUTURE.
THE CLIMATE SCIENTISTS ARE
TELLING US THAT WE SHOULD SEE
MORE AND MORE SEVERE WILD FIRES
IN THE STATE.
AND ALSO WARMING MORE ACIDIC
OCEANS -- IMPORTANTLY EACH ONE
OF THOSE THE FAX.
COULD BE DRAMATIC FOR ANY
INDIVIDUAL REGION IN THE STATE --
BUT IMPORTANTLY IF YOU LOOK
ACROSS THE WHOLE STATE WE TO
EXPECT EVERY REGION TO IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD TO EXPERIENCE ONE IF
NOT MORE THAN ONE OF THOSE A FAX --
INNING CONSEQUENTLY WE WOULD
EXPECT TO SEE BASED ON THE
CLIMATE SCIENCE IS TELLING US.
THAT THOSE ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS
COULD HAVE SIGNIFICANT EFFECTS
FOR THINGS LIKE PUBLIC HEALTH
THE HIGH HEAT EVENT FOR EXAMPLE
COULD HAVE.
SIGNIFICANT BANKS ON AS ASTHMA
RATES AND AND INCREASED
MORTALITY.
YOU COULD SEE A REDUCE WATER
SUPPLY BECAUSE OF DROUGHT.
REDUCE WATER SUPPLY FOR
IRRIGATION IN OUR AGRICULTURAL
REGIONS.
YOU COULD SEE PUBLIC SAFETY
IMPACT BECAUSE OF EVENTS LIKE
FLOODING IN WILD FIRES.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE THREE OF THE
HAND NOW -- SO ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS WERE SOMETIMES ASK AND
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE ECONOMIC
AND FISCAL A FAX.
OF THESE ENVIRONMENTAL CHANGES
IN THE FUTURE IN IN THE SHORT
ANSWER WE DON'T KNOW A LOT YET --
THERE ARE THERE IS SOME RESEARCH
OUT THEN WE TRY TO SUMMARIZE A
LITTLE BIT OF THAT HERE IN THE
HAND OUT.
BUT WITH REGARD TO LONGER TERM
ECONOMIC IMPACT PROBABLY THE
BEST STUDY THAT WE'VE COME
ACROSS SO FAR.
DONE BY A GROUP OF RESEARCHERS
AND INCLUDING SOME FROM OUR OWN
UC BERKELEY.
AND THEY LOOK NATION WIDE AT
CERTAIN ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WOULD THAT AFFECT ON
GDP BE.
IN DIFFERENT AREAS BASED ON WHAT
THE THE FACTS WOULD BE -- BASED
ON THEIR RESEARCH THEY WOULD AS
WE WOULD SORT OF PUT ON THE
ORDER OF MAGNITUDE OF TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN LOST CDP
IN CALIFORNIA ON AN ANNUAL BASIS --
OUT IN -- TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
TAKE THAT WITH -- AS SORT OF AN
ORDER OF MAGNITUDE THERE'S A
CERTAINLY A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY
AROUND THAT IN THE AUTHOR'S NOTE
TO THAT ONE OF THE LIMITATIONS
OF THEIR STUDY IS THEY COULD
LOOK AT THE FULL RANGE OF
IMPACTS OF OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
SO THIS PARTICULAR IMPORTANT
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE A COUPLE.
OF PIECES THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO
INCLUDE WERE THE EFFECTS OF WILD
FIRE WHICH WE KNOW CALIFORNIA
COURSE HAS VERY SEVERE RISKS.
AS WELL AS SEALEVEL RISE THEY
LOOK AT SEA LEVEL RISE THAT
SPECIFICALLY ASSOCIATED WITH
HURRICANES -- I THINK THE THAT
WE EXPECT THE AFFECTION
CALIFORNIA SEA LEVEL RISE TO BE
SIGNIFICANT BUT NOT SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO HURRICANES.
AND SO JUST -- ADDED HERE JUST
VERY RECENTLY LAST COUPLE WEEKS
THE USGS.
LOOK AT WHAT ALONG THE
CALIFORNIA COAST IS ESTIMATED
THE PROPERTY VALUE AT RISK FROM
EVEN MODERATE SEA LEVEL RISE
OVER THE NEXT EIGHTY YEARS AND
THEY PUT IT AT A HUNDRED FIFTY
BILLION DOLLARS.
OF VALUE -- ISN'T.
BUT NO THAT'S NOT THE AMOUNT
THAT WE WOULD ANTICIPATE BEING
LOST NECESSARILY BUT THAT'S THE
AMOUNT OF RISK AND AGAIN TO GIVE
YOU.
AT LEAST A POINT.
ON ORDER OF MAGNITUDE OF
POTENTIAL RISK.
BUT THAT'S THE ECONOMIC EFFECTS
SOMETIMES WHAT WERE ASKED WHAT
WHAT'S THE RISK TO STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHAT TO OUR
FINANCES.
AGAIN WE DON'T HAVE A GOOD
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS OF THIS --
WE'VE DONE SOME LOOKING AND AND
WE WERE ABLE TO COME ACROSS GOOD
INFORMATION ON THAT.
THAT SAID WE DO KNOW THAT THE
TYPES OF IMPACTS WE'VE SORTOF
CATEGORIZED.
IN THREE WAYS FIRST OF ALL YOU
WOULD EXPECT THAT STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE GONNA HAVE
INCREASED THE COST TO RESPOND TO
DISASTERS LIKE FLOODS.
AND WILDFIRES. TO THE EXTENT
THAT CLIMATE CHANGE CONTINUE
THEN HAS THE THE FACTS THAT ARE
PROJECTED YOU WOULD EXPECT TO
SEE INCREASED COSTS FOR DISASTER
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY.
JUST TO GIVE YOU ONE POINT OF OF
REFERENCE THE CAMPFIRE THIS LAST
YEAR THE STATE.
IS BUDGETING THREE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY COSTS JUST FOR THAT ONE
EVENT ALONE.
WORTH NOTING OF COURSE THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL
REIMBURSE US FOR A LARGE SHARE
THAT COST BUT GIVE YOU AGAIN
IT'S NOT AN ORDER OF MAGNITUDE
FROM AS A SINGLE EVENT.
WE ALSO EXPECT TO SEE ANNUAL
OPERATING COSTS GO UP IN THE
FUTURE FOR STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. FOR PREVENTIVE
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS WELFARE
PREVENTION OR FLOOD MAINTENANCE
AND IMPROVEMENT ACTIVITIES --
THAT MIGHT MEAN NEED TO BE DONE
ON A ROUTINE BASIS COULD SEE
INCREASE IN ENERGY COSTS AND
OTHER ONGOING OPERATING COSTS.
AND LASTLY WE MIGHT EXPECT TO
SEE ONE TIME OUT LAYS FROM STATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO HARDEN
FACILITIES OR IN SOME CASES
RELOCATE FACILITIES IN ORDER TO
TAKE THEM OUT OF THE DANGER ZONE.
YOU KNOW FROM SEA LEVEL RISE OR
WILD FIRES OR OTHER POTENTIAL --
RISKY AREAS -- IF YOU TURN THE
PAGE FOR A MINUTE CHANGE GEARS
AND TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
STATE BONDS.
THE STATE.
CAN I TAKE PAYS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN TWO
WAYS WE DO SOME ON A PAY AS YOU
GO BASIS WE DON'T DO A LOT OF
THAT WITH THE GENERAL FUND
THAT'S FAIRLY LIMITED
HISTORICALLY.
WHAT WE DO ISSUE BONDS AND -- WE
HAVE TO TYPE THE BOND IN THE
STATE GENERAL OBLIGATION BONDS
OF THE ONE TO HAVE TO GO TO
VOTERS STATE WIDE VOTERS WE ALSO
HAVE SOME USE OF LEASE REVENUE
BONDS.
BONDS YOU CAN THINK OF IS JUST A
WAY TO BORROW MONEY ITS.
WE ISSUE THE BONDS PRIVATE
INVESTORS PROVIDE US MONEY WE
USE THAT MONEY TO PAY FOR
PROJECTS AND THEN WE HAVE TO
REPAY THOSE INVESTORS OVER A
PERIOD OF YEARS OFTENTIMES
TWENTY OR THIRTY YEARS. FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE BONDS.
MUCH LIKE THE WAY WE PAY FOR OUR
HOUSE WITH AND PAY FOR MORTGAGE
FOR A HOUSE WE BORROWED HAVE TO
PAY IT BACK WITH INTEREST OVER
TIME.
WE DO THIS SO FOR A COUPLE OF OF
GOOD REASONS -- WE KNOW THE
OFTENTIMES THESE LARGE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS CAN BE
DIFFICULT TO PAY FOR ON A PAGE
YOU GO BASIS BECAUSE OF THE
MAGNITUDE OF COSTS -- AGAIN
PARTICULAR LARGE PROJECTS.
AND ALSO THERE'S SOME.
VALUE IN THESE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE
A LONGER LIFESPAN FOR TAXPAYERS
OF FEE PAYERS NOT ONLY TODAY BUT
THOSE IN THE FUTURE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE COST OF THOSE
PROJECTS BECAUSE THEY'LL BENEFIT
FROM THEM AS WELL -- WHICH
SOMETIMES ASK WHAT WAS THE COST
OF FINANCING WITH THE BOND -- IN
NOMINAL DOLLARS IT'S USUALLY WE
ULTIMATELY WILL PAY WITH THOSE
INTEREST COST ABOUT TWO DOLLARS
FOR EVERY DOLLAR IN BOND
ISSUANCE.
BUT WHEN WE COUNT FOR THE FACT
THAT WE PAY THOSE COSTS OFF OVER
TWENTY OR THIRTY YEAR PERIOD
WHEN YOU COUNT FOR INFLATION IT
TEND TO BE MORE LIKE A DOLLAR
AND THIRTY CENTS AN ACTUAL REAL
DOLLARS THAT WE'RE SPENDING. FOR
EACH DOLLAR ISSUED SO THERE ARE
INCREASE COSTS BUT SOMETIMES
THERE'S SOME CONFUSION ABOUT
JUST WHAT THOSE COSTS ARE SO FOR
THAT SO FULL.
YOU TURN TO PAGE FIVE JUST THIS
JUST SUMMARIZE IT FOR YOU THE A
NATURAL RESOURCES RELATED BONDS
AND BEEN ISSUED OVER THE PAST
TWO DECADES.
THE TOTAL ABOUT THIRTY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN.
TOTAL BOND AUTHORITY.
MOST OF THIS MONEY HAS ALREADY
BEEN COMMITTED TO PROJECTS AND
SPENT PROBABLY THE TWO
EXCEPTIONS OR THE LAST.
TWO PROPOSITION ONE WHICH IS THE
FAMILIAR WATER RELATED BOND
PASSED IN -- TWENTY FOURTEEN NOT
ALL THAT MONEY HAS BEEN SPENT%
YET -- BUT MOST OF IT HAD BEEN
COMMITTED TO TO PROJECTS SO
THERE ARE PROJECTS UNDER WAY AND
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT AND
CONSTRUCTION PHASES.
AND WITH PROP PROPOSITION SIXTY
EIGHT WITH PAST LESS THAN A YEAR
AGO BUT ALREADY BETWEEN THE
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET AND WITH
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR IF APPROVED BY YOU
ALSO THAT WILL HAVE AUTHORIZED
OR APPROPRIATED.
ABOUT HALF OF THE TOTAL FOR
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
AUTHORIZED HIM OUT BONTA THAT
ONE IS ALSO WELL ANYWAY.
AND IF YOU TURN TO PAGE SIX JUST
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT STATE
INDEBTEDNESS.
THE FIGURE AT THE BOTTOM OF THIS
PAGE SHOWS OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF DECADES WHAT SHARE.
OF STATE GENERAL FUND REVENUES
ARE SPENT ON PAYING OFF OUR
GENERAL FUND BOND MOSTLY GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND AGAIN.
AND YOU CAN SEE RIGHT NOW WE'RE
TO A LITTLE BIT LESS THAN 5% OF
OUR OVERALL GENERAL FUND IS
SPENT FOR THAT PURPOSE -- AND
YOU CAN SEE THAT FALLS KIND OF
IN A RANGE A NORMAL RANGE OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF DECADES.
THIS VARIATION USING THE FIGURE
IS NOT REALLY DRIVEN PRIMARILY
BY CHANGES IN HOW MUCH BOND
ISSUE IT ISSUED ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS AS MUCH AS IS AFFECTED BY.
GENERAL FUND REVENUES IN THE
VOLATILITY OF OUR REVENUE STREAM
IN THE STATE AND SO IS.
GENERAL FUND REVENUES GO UP ARE
THE PERCENTAGE SPENT ON BOND
ISSUANCES DECLINES AND AND VICE
VERSA -- I KNOW THAT A ROUGHLY
ABOUT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IT'S BEEN OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND TO PAY OFF
RESOURCES RELATED BONDS.
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN ISSUED.
ON PAGE -- SEVEN THESE ARE A
COUPLE OF CONSIDERATIONS WHEN
DESIGNING BONDS THESE COME FROM
VARIOUS DOCUMENTS OUR OFFICE IS
PRODUCED.
IN PRIOR YEARS RELATED TO TO
VERY SMALL AND MEASURES.
FIRST WE JUST HIGHLIGHTED
THERE'S REALLY NO RIGHT LEVEL OF
SPENDING ON INFRASTRUCTURE OR
BOND AT IT.
LIKE EVERY OTHER BUDGET PROGRAM
YOU HAVE IT'S REALLY A FOR
REFLECTION OF HOW.
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE FALLS WITHIN
YOUR PRIORITIES FOR GENERAL FUND
SPENDING BECAUSE OF COURSE EVERY
DOLLAR THAT YOU SPEND ON
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT AVAILABLE
FOR OTHER PROGRAMS -- ONE THING
THAT MAKES SPENDING ON BOND A
LITTLE BIT UNIQUE OF COURSE IS
THAT.
BECAUSE WE'RE MAKING THAT TWENTY
OR THIRTY YEAR COMMITMENT TO PAY
OFF THOSE BONDS YOU'RE NOT JUST
MAKING A ONE YEAR COMMITMENT FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE YOU ARE YOU
SHOULD RECOGNIZE THAT.
THOSE COSTS ARE GONNA BE IN THE
BUDGET.
AND THEREFORE NOT AVAILABLE FOR
OTHER PURPOSES FOR A LONGER
PERIOD THAT'S NOT TO SAY IT'S
NOT WORTH DOING BUT YOU JUST
WANNA RECOGNIZE THAT AS YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT YOUR LONGER TERM.
PRIORITIES.
ON THE SECOND.
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE THESE BONDS
ARE PAID OFF OVER LONG PERIODS
IMPORTANT WE THINK.
TO A TARGET BONDS TO PROJECT
THAT WILL HAVE A LONGER LIFESPAN
WE GENERALLY DO NOT RECOMMEND
FUNDING SHORT TERM PROJECTS OR
OR ANNUAL OPERATING AND
MAINTENANCE TYPES COST FOR THE
MOST PART.
FROM ONE CONSIDERATION YOU'LL
ALSO HAVE IS HOW MUCH OF A YOUR
BOND SHOULD BE SPENT ON STATE
VERSUS LOCAL PROJECTS THERE'S NO
RIGHT OR WRONG SPLIT TO THIS BUT
CERTAINLY IT IS APPROPRIATE FOR
THE STATE TO USE BOND FOR STATE
PROJECTS EITHER INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE OWN AND OPERATE. TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO CALIFORNIANS --
SOMETIMES A LITTLE MORE DEBATE
ABOUT HOW THEY SHOULD BE HOW
MUCH OF BOND SHOULD BE TARGETED
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE LOCAL
PROJECTS -- HISTORICALLY AS A
STAY AREN'T RESOURCES BONDS HAVE
PROVIDED FUNDING FOR LOCAL
PROJECT SOMETIMES TARGETED
TOWARDS COMMUNITIES OTHERWISE
DON'T HAVE SUFFICIENT.
RESOURCES TO PAY FOR PROJECTS ON
THEIR OWN.
OR JUST OTHER HIGH PRIORITY
NEEDS OR SOMETIMES REGIONAL
PROJECTS -- PROJECTS WHERE THERE
MAY NOT BE LOCAL INCENTIVE. FOR
LOCAL COLLABORATION SOMETIMES WE
CAN USE OUR BOND FUNDS OR OTHER
REVENUE STREAMS TO HELP.
ENCOURAGE THAT KIND OF ACTIVITY.
YOU ALSO WHEN I THINK ABOUT HOW
YOU DISTRIBUTE THE BOND WITH THE
ONE YOU THE COMPETITIVE PROCESS
OR FORMULA.
PROSELYTE THAT MAY JUST DEPEND
ON EACH INDIVIDUAL BOND PROGRAM
WHAT.
WELL WHAT YOU WANT ENCOURAGE
WHETHER CERTAIN SPECIFIC GOALS
THAT YOU WANT TO TRY TO ACHIEVE
IN WHICH CASE MAYBE COMPETITIVE
PROCESS IS.
MORE VALUABLE OR IF YOU REALLY
ARE YOUR GOAL IS TO SPREAD --
CERTAIN FINDING EQUALLY ACROSS
THE STATE AND YOU MIGHT USE A
FORMULA -- WE ALSO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT.
OF PRETTY GOOD FOR PROJECTS TO
GO TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
LOCAL NONPROFITS THAT THEY HAVE
A PLAN IN PLACE TO MAINTAIN THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE OVER THE LONGER
TERM FOR THAT THEY DON'T.
BECOME DILAPIDATED -- BEFORE
THEIR USEFUL LIFE SHOULD AND AND
LASTLY RESOURCES BONDS IN RECENT
YEARS HAVE.
INCLUDED PROVISIONS REQUIRING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND REPORTING OF
PROJECT WE THINK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. TO ENSURE THAT.
YOU KNOW AND CAN DO YOUR
OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE THAT YOU
KNOW WHAT.
WHAT PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED HOW THEY'VE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED ON WHAT TIME FRAME
IT ALSO PROVIDES INFORMATION FOR
FUTURE?
DELIBERATIONS FOR FUTURE BOND
YOU CAN LOOK BACK AND SEE WHAT
WHAT DID.
THAT BOND ACCOMPLISH DO WE NEED
TO MAYBE MAKE ANY CHANGES IN TO
A FUTURE BOND BASED ON LESSONS
LEARNED.
FROM WHAT'S REPORTED HERE.
THERE'S A JUST GENERAL GENERAL
KNOW SOMEONE IN GENERAL LAST
LAST TWO PAGES DAM PAGE EIGHT
I'M.
HERE WE WERE ASKED WHAT OTHER.
REVENUE SOURCES ARE FUNDING
SOURCES COULD BE MADE AVAILABLE.
FOR CLIMB ADAPTATION
[inaudible]
JACK'S.
WE KIND OF CATEGORIZES INTO A
YOU CAN LOOK AT YOUR EXISTING
REVENUES THAT YOU HAVE AVAILABLE
DIFFERENT POTS AND AND THE
FORTIES.
AND THEN OF COURSE YOU ARE A YOU
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
AUTHORITY O RAISE NEW REVENUES.
THE FIRST WITH RESPECT TO
EXISTING REVENUE SOURCES -- I
THINK THE KEY THING HERE AGAIN
IS TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
YOU YOU CAN USE ALMOST ANY OF
THESE BUT TO EXTENT THERE IS THE
OPPORTUNITY COST TO TO EXTEND TO
YOU THAT FOR ONE PURPOSE IS NOT
AVAILABLE FOR FOR ANOTHER FOR
ANOTHER.
BUDGET PRIORITY BUT CERTAINLY
STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE THE
pGENERAL FUND THERE ARE MANY
SPECIAL FUNDS THAT CAN BE USED
FOR CLIMATE ADAPTATION PROJECTS
FOR EXAMPLE THE STATE IS YOU THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FIND ON
A LIMITED BASIS.
FOR ADAPTATION SPECIFIC RELATED
PROJECTS -- LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FOR EXAMPLE COULD HAVE SOME FEES
WHILE WATER RELATED FEEDER FLOOD
PROTECTION FEE THAT COULD BE
USED FOR PROJECTS THAT COULD
HELP.
CLIMATE CHANGE RISK FOR EXAMPLE.
LOCAL.
IN ADDITION TO STATE THE LOCALS
ALSO HAVE AUTHORITY TO ISSUE
BONDS.
IN ONE SPECIFIC BOND AUTHORITY
IS THE ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICT THIS I.
AN AUTHORITY THAT WAS GRANTED BY
THE LEGISLATURE JUST A FEW YEARS
AGO IN THE AFTERMATH OF A
DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT.
IN THIS ALLOWS CITIES COUNTIES
AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS TO USED
PROPERTY TAX INCREMENTS OF THE
GROWTH IN PROPERTY TAX REVENUES.
TO PAY OFF BOND ISSUANCES -- IN
ONE OF THE EXPLICIT ALLOWABLE
USES IN THE CODE IS TO YOU TO
FINANCE CLIMATE ADAPTATION
PROJECTS THAT WE COULD BE AN
ALLOWABLE USE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
IN LESS THAN ONE HIGHLIGHTED THE
STATE DOES IN IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT IS WELL
RECEIVED FEDERAL FUNDING IT'S
RELATIVELY SMALL FOR THE MOST
PART.
OFTEN FOR PLANNING AND RESEARCH
TYPE ACTIVITIES AND SOMETIMES
SMALLER SCALE -- ADAPTATION TYPE
PROJECT BUT I DID WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU -- THE HAZARD
MITIGATION GRANT PROGRAM THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HIGHLIGHTED IN
OUR BUDGET ANALYSIS THIS HERE.
THIS IS FUNDING THAT COMES TO
STATE IN THE AFTERMATH FROM FEMA
IN THE AFTERMATH OF LARGE
DISASTERS AND BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA'S HAVE THE VERY LARGE
WILDFIRE DISASTERS THE LAST FEW
YEARS.
WE'RE ANTICIPATING THE STATE
WILL RECEIVE ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS IN THIS FUNDING OVER THE
NEXT YEAR OR SO -- WE HIGHLIGHT
IN OUR BUDGET IS TO MAKE YOU
AWARE -- YES.
MANAGE THAT PROGRAM AND THEY SET
CRITERIA FOR WHAT PROJECT WILL
BE -- FOR WILL BE FUNDED AND
CERTAIN CLIMATE ADAPTATION TYPE
OF ACTIVITIES ARE ALLOWABLE USES
OF THOSE FUNDS WE'VE RECOMMENDED
THE LEGISLATURE THAT YOU REVIEW
OF YESES PLANS INTO THE EXTENT
THAT THEIR PRIORITIES ARE.
IN SOME CASES DIFFER FROM YOURS
THAT PROVIDING SOME ADDITIONAL
DIRECTION ON HOW TO HOW TO
DIRECT THOSE FUNDS.
LASTLY ON PAGE -- NINE AGAIN IS
THAT THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ARE CERTAINLY AWARE
STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
AUTHORITY TO RAISE REVENUES --
THAT CAN BE BROAD BASED TAX
INCREASES THE INCREASES CHARGED
ON POLLUTERS.
EACH ONE OF THESE -- DOES COME
WITH THE CONCERT AND CONSTRAINTS
AGAIN AS I'M SURE THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE WELL AWARE -- BUT
WHETHER THOSE BE DIFFERENT
VOTING THRESHOLD OR REQUIREMENT
FOR PROPERTY TAX.
I'M SORRY PROPERTY OWNERS TO TO
VOTE ON CERTAIN FEES ARE
ASSESSMENTS -- WE JUST HIGHLIGHT
HERE THAT -- THESE ARE AVENUES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE AND COULD BE
USED FOR CLIMATE ADAPTATION
PROJECT BUT AGAIN THERE ARE
CERTAIN CONSTRAINTS ON THOSE
WHETHER THOSE BE LIMITATIONS
LIKE I'M PROP THIRTEEN FROM PROP
THIRTEEN ON THE MATTER PROPERTY
TAX REVENUE LOCALS COULD YOU.
CAN CAN REYES -- OR OTHER VOTING.
RESTRICTIONS OR CONSTRAINTS.
SO I THINK THAT REALLY CONCLUDE
MY REMARKS AND HAPPY TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU -- THE CONCISE BUT
VERY USEFUL TESTIMONY -- I I
JUST TO START OVER THE ONE IN.
LINE OF QUESTIONS JUST IN TERMS
OF THE THE MATH AROUND COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF ADDRESSING
CLIMATE CHANGE [inaudible]
AND WE WE ROLLED BY THE NUMBER
BUT IT'S A REALLY BIG.
ONE WE'RE SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TENS
OF BILLIONS [inaudible]
AND SOME OTHER UNKNOWN UPPER
BOUND -- I'M REALLY HOPING OUR
FIFTH CLIMATE ASSESSMENT IN THE
STATE STARTS.
TO DRILL DOWN ON THE TRUE FISCAL
RISK BUT I GUESS I WAS WONDERING
[inaudible]
THE IT'S ABOUT A BUCK THIRTY FOR
EACH DOLLAR PART OF THESE BONDS
THIS IS SORT OF ROUGH WORKING
MATH.
BUT IF THE COST OF CLIMATE
CHANGE IS A A TRILLION DOLLARS
BY THE END OF THE CENTURY
[inaudible]
I'M.
HOW DOES THAT AFFECT?
THEY ARE MATH WE MAKE EVEN JUST
CERTAIN PRESUMPTIONS IN THE LIFE
OF THE BOND STATE YOU KNOW
TWENTY OR THIRTY YEAR BASIS --
HOW DOES THAT SORT OF AVOIDED
COST AFFECT?
THAT MATH AROUND BUCK THIRTY PER
DOLLAR.
YEAH I MICHIGAN TO THE ATH IN
MY HEAD BUT I THINK -- I THINK
AND SEXUALLY IF I UNDERSTAND
YOUR QUESTION I I THINK YOU'RE
ASKING A QUESTION WHICH IS.
KEY CENTER WE MAKE THESE
INVESTMENTS TODAY EVEN IF THERE
ARE ADDITIONAL.
IN INFLATION OR I'M SORRY.
INTEREST RELATED COSTS.
COULD SPENDING THOSE DOLLARS
TODAY REDUCE FUTURE COSTS AND
AND AND THE MATH WORK OUT THAT
THAT'S A BETTER INVESTMENT TODAY
THAN THAN WAITING FOR THOSE
DISASTERS OR FUTURE COSTS MATURE
THAT AND I THINK CONCEPTUALLY
THAT THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT --
WE OFTENTIMES THINK ABOUT EVEN
JUST IN OUR MAINTENANCE PROGRAM
FOR STATE INFRASTRUCTURE WE'RE
REGULATE ADVISING YOU IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PUT MORE MONEY
INTO PREVENTIVE ACTIVITIES TO
ENSURE THAT OUR INFRASTRUCTURE.
IS NOT DAMAGE IN THE FUTURE
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT.
THERE ARE SO MANY EXAMPLES WHERE
IF WE WAIT FOR A FACILITY TO BE
DAMAGE THE COSTS ARE MUCH
GREATER. TO REPAIR OR REPLACE
THAT FACILITY AND TO DO THE WORK
UP FRONT NOW I GET SOMEWHAT
COMPLICATED BECAUSE THIS IS
SOMEWHAT CONCEPTUAL WHAT.
WHAT THE SPECIFIC PROJECTS WOULD
BE RIGHT -- IF WE THINK ABOUT.
SEA LEVEL RISE FOR EXAMPLE.
THERE'S A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT OR IN IN PROBABLY VERY
FROM COMMUNITY COMMUNITY ABOUT
WHAT THE RIGHT STRATEGY SHOULD
BE BASED ON WHAT THEIR LOCAL
RISKS ARE FROM SEA LEVEL RISE.
AND WEATHER MAKES SENSE. FOR
CERTAIN FOR CERTAIN PROJECT TO
DO HARDENING TYPE PROJECTS OR TO
DO PROJECTS.
WHICH HAVE COME WITH ONE SET OF
COST TO DO OTHER PROJECTS THAT
MIGHT MAKE THEM IN SOME WAYS --
JUST MORE ABLE TO WITHSTAND.
SEA LEVEL RISE TO MAYBE RAISING
OF A BUILDING FOR EXAMPLE THAT
COULD COME WITH A DIFFERENT SET
OF COST WHICH IS ACTUALLY HAVING
TO MOVE.
THE SALIENT SO THERE'S BEEN TALK
FOR EXAMPLE ABOUT.
CERTAIN FREEWAYS ARE CERTAIN
ROADS ACTUALLY HAVING TO BE
REDIRECTED IN DIFFERENT PLACES
BECAUSE OF THE RISK OF A
ROTATION ALONG THE COAST.
THAT COMES WITH A DIFFERENT SET
OF COST AND SO IT TO DO THE MATH
I THINK EARLIER IN SOME WAYS
REQUIRES REALLY LOOKING AT THIS.
SPECIFIC PROJECT A PROGRAM IN
FIGURING OUT WHAT THOSE FUTURE
COSTS WOULD WOULD BE BUT I THINK
IN IN PRINCIPLE YES.
INVESTING IN SOONER TO REDUCE
RISK LOOK POTENTIALLY VERY LARGE
AND EXPENSIVE RISK IN THE FUTURE
CAN CAN MAKE SENSE SO IN THEORY
THERE'S A WAY TO DESIGN.
A RESOURCES TYPE ON THAT
[inaudible]
SAVE MONEY [inaudible]
OVER TIME.
I WOULD I WOULD THINK SO AGAIN I
WOULD JUST I WOULD JUST.
OF COURSE THERE THIS COMES WITH
A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY BUT BUT BUT
CERTAINLY IN THEORY YEAH I THINK
PUTTING MONEY IN TODAY CAN BE
USED IF IT'S IF YOU'RE.
IF SOME SOME THIS MAY COME TO TO
HOW YOU THINK ABOUT ANY SPECIFIC
BOND HOW YOU PRIORITIZE YOUR
PROGRAM THE COST EFFECTIVENESS
COULD BE ONE PRIORITY THAT YOU
<c.magenta>OOK AT WHEN YOU'RE THINKING</c>
ABOUT HOW WHAT PROGRAMS YOU WANT
TO INVEST IN.
AS WELL AS WHAT SPECIFIC
CRITERIA USED FOR ANY INDIVIDUAL
PROGRAM.
BUT EVEN IF YOU I MEAN. TO GET.
BEYOND THEORY THOUGH IF YOU TAKE
A TRILLION DOLLAR RISK AND
YOU'RE BUYING DOWN TEN BILLION
DOLLARS THAT RISK -- FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OF THAT RISK YOU
STILL HAVE.
A NINETY FIVE OR NINETY BILLION
DOLLAR LIABILITY.
I MEAN I I I I WOULD WE LOVE
SOME INPUT I THINK JUST IN TERMS
A LEVEL SETTING THE SCOPE OF
INVESTMENT THAT WERE EVEN
CONSIDERING HERE TODAY.
STACKED UP AGAINST THE SCOPE OF
THE RISK AND JUST ACKNOWLEDGING
AT LEAST ON AN ORDER OF
MAGNITUDE BASIS THAT LIKE.
EVEN IF THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A
TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR CLIMATE
RESILIENCY BOND.
THIS IS THE THE THE RISK OVER
THAT SAME PERIOD TIME IS FAR
GREATER -- AND SO WHAT YEAH IT'S
JUST IT IT.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WOULD HELP
US JUST SORT OF LEVEL SET IN
TERMS OF OUR PRIORITIES I THINK
UNDER.
IF IF WE WERE TO FALLOW FARMING
IN ALL THE CENTRAL VALLEY
BECAUSE THE DROUGHTS.
AND ALL THE GROUND WATER DRIED
UP AND YOU KNOW WE MAY SEE YOU
KNOW THE COTTON YIELDS ARE DOWN
80% AND YEAH THESE KIND OF COST
STACK UP IN A SERIOUS WAY VERSUS
SOME OTHER STRATEGY TO AVERT
THAT SO IS THERE SOME WAY THAT
YOU CAN.
GET BACK TO US TO JUST WITH THEM.
EVEN IF IT'S NOT A MY PERFECT
MATH SOME WAY TO SORT OF SCOPE.
A RISK BY DOWN STRATEGIES FOR
OURSELVES YEAH I MEAN WE
CERTAINLY CAN I CAN GO BACK AND
WORK WITH OUR TEAM OF FOLKS AT
THE OFFICE AND AND SEE IF
THERE'S SOME WAY WE CAN PRESENT
THAT -- THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
YOU WERE HAPPY TO DO THAT -- I I
GUESS MAYBE JUST I WOULD ADD AS
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT THIS.
THINKING BOTH ABOUT ERROR OR
BEING CLEAR FOR YOURSELF ABOUT
IT WHAT RISKY BY NOW WE'RE
BRINGING.
WE TAKE THAT WE WANT TO BUY DOWN
OVERALL ECONOMIC RISK -- VERSES
WHAT IS THE RISK TO THE STATE
FINANCES SPECIFICALLY THOSE ARE --
I THINK BOTH IMPORTANT QUESTION
BUT THEY'RE A LITTLE BIT
DISTINCT.
AND THEN AGAIN GOING BACK TO
POINT A I ALLUDED TO EARLIER
THINKING ABOUT. SIX AND THAT
SOME OF THESE RISKS -- ARE TO
LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE OR PRIVATE
PROPERTY TO WHAT EXTENT IS THAT
DO YOU WANT THAT TO BE THE STATE --
PAIN FOR TO BUY DOWN THAT RISK
VERSES COULD THAT BE LOOK THERE
SHOULD BE A LOCAL BUY IN FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR SHOULD THAT
BE.
AN INDIVIDUAL PRIVATE PROPERTY
OWNERS TYPE OF RESPONSIBILITY.
THANK YOU COMMENTS QUESTIONS YES
CEREMONY.
COME OF THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
ALEJO'S OFFICER PRECIADO.
THE FRAMING AND PRESENTATION.
SO WHAT KIND OF PICKING UP ON
THE CHAIR LEANS IN YOUR
PROJECTION ON ESTIMATED PROPERTY
VALUE AT RISK A HUNDRED FIFTY
BILLION.
BASED ON MY TO SEA LEVEL RISE.
PROJECTED TO KERR BY.
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED SO THAT'S ONE
ESTIMATED.
LIABILITY OF THAT HUNDRED FIFTY
BILLION.
ARM.
HOW DO YOU ADDRESS IT?
WHAT PERCENTAGE MIGHT BE
ELIGIBLE FOR SOME FEDERAL
[inaudible]
SUPPORT VERSES.
DRAG ON THE GENERAL FUND VERSUS
BOND FUNDING IN.
IN.
JUST TAKE ONE FIGURE LIKE THAT
IN MAY BE BREAK OUT A LITTLE
LATER THE PATHWAYS.
IN IN YEARS TO PAY THAT OFF.
I'M ANOTHER QUESTION I HAD ON
PAGE SIX WHERE -- WE'VE REDUCE
SOME. TO BELOW 5% THE ANNUAL
INTEREST RATE WE'RE PAYING ON
OUR OUR OBLIGATIONS.
AND YOU INDICATED THAT THAT
FIGURES AFFECTED SOMEWHAT BY OUR
GENERAL REVENUES.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SENSE OF HOW
THAT COMPARES TO OTHER STATES
YOU SAID THERE'S NOT REALLY ARE
A CORRECT TARGET DATE.
WE'RE JUST CALIFORNIA SIT FOR
EXAMPLE WITH OUR DEBT
OBLIGATIONS VERSES OTHER STATES
OF SIMILAR SIZE.
YEAH I AM ALL HAVE TO GO BACK
AND DOUBLE CHECK OF LOOKED AT
THOSE NUMBERS BUT NOT VERY
RECENTLY MY GENERAL RECOLLECTION
IS WE'RE KIND OF IN THE NORMAL
RANGE ONE ON OUT LIAR BUT I CAN
GO BACK AND AND GIVE YOU MORE
PRECISE.
INFORMATION AND IT SEEMS LIKE
ONE ONE FUNCTION OF THAT PERCENT
IS.
OUR OUR REVENUES.
FROM.
WE'VE ALSO XCELERATED.
INTEREST PAYMENTS IN SOME RECENT
BUDGET SAYS THAT CRACKED HIS AT
BEEN ON BOND AT SERVICERS THAT
JUST BEEN HONOR.
PENSION LIABILITIES.
I'M SO OUR INTEREST RATES ARE
ARE NOT SET BY THE BY THE STATE
ITS IT'S DETERMINED BY THE
MARKETS IN FRANK.
IN SO -- BUT WE CAN STILL LOOK
CELERY ARE.
INTEREST PAYMENTS HONEST YES THE
STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE IS
AGENCY INVOLVED WITH MANAGING
OUR OUR BOND DAY IN SO THEY WILL
THEY'LL THEY'LL -- ON A ROUTINE
BASIS RE ISSUE BOND IN SOME
CASES ARE LIKE -- PROBABLY IN
SOME CASES PREPAY BOND DEPENDING
ON THEIR CALCULATION OF HOW THAT
WILL YIELD THE BEST RETURN FOR
THE STATE OR THE LOWEST COST
OVER OVER THE LONG RUN INSIGHT I
THEY ACTIVELY MANAGE.
THAT PORTFOLIO.
CAN I WOULD BE CURIOUS JUST TO
SEE AGAIN I REALIZE SETS.
CERTAINLY FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE
THAT. 5% IS NOT AN ALARMING.
FIGURE THAT'S WITHIN THE
BALLPARK OF REASONABLE.
YEAH I I BELIEVE IT IS BUT I'LL
DEFINITELY GET BACK TO YOU WITH
THE SPECIFICS THANK YOU WE RANK
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATE CAREER.
NOT SURE HAVE A QUESTION HERE
BUT BUT I AM.
WHAT WHAT MAY MAKE SENSE?
AS WE GET INTO FUTURE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE RISKS.
FROM DIFFERENT.
ACTIVITIES WHETHER IT'S FIRE
ACTIVITY WHETHER IT'S C. RISE
WHETHER IT'S DROUGHT -- THAT WE
MAY WANT TO ASK -- OUR EXPERTS
TO COME IN AND DO A PANEL ON
WHAT SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
IMPACTS AND SOME OF THE
SOLUTIONS MIGHT BE -- BUT I I A
IT'S A WORD OF CAUTION BECAUSE
WE HAD SOME MODELING DONE A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO [inaudible]
BACK IN. EIGHT AND NINE THAT
SHOWED THAT IF WE HAD A MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE.
IN THE DELTA.
ANYWHERE ABOVE SIX POINT.
TWO THAT THE REPERCUSSIONS WERE
SUCH THAT WE MIGHT LOSE.
THE SOURCE OF WATER.
BECAUSE OF THE THE MIXTURE OF
SALT AND FRESHWATER.
ANY IMPACT TWO THIRDS OF THE
STATE'S.
POPULATION BY THAT AND FRANKLY I
HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING THAT TELLS
US THAT WE STARTED TO TAKE CARE
OF SOME OF THAT.
SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS.
THROUGH THE BONDS THAT WE'VE
PASSED THAT WOULD PROVIDE US
WITH A DEGREE OF CERTAINTY THAT
THAT WOULDN'T HAPPEN THAT THERE
WERE THERE BECAUSE THERE WERE
SOME SOLUTIONS.
BUYING BUYING PROPERTY CREATING
STORAGE AND ALL THAT KIND OF
GOOD STUFF SO SO I JUST THINK
THAT THE MORE THE MORE
INFORMATION WE HAVE THE BETTER.
OFF WILL BE BUT I ALSO THINK AS
A NOTE OF CAUTION THAT WE HAVE
TO TIE.
THE THE SOLUTIONS TO THE BONDS.
SO THAT IN A VERY DELIBERATE WAY
WE DON'T USE THEM FOR OTHER
THINGS BASED ON KIND OF THE THE
WHATEVER IS HAPPENING AT THAT
PARTICULAR POINT IN TIME SO I I
DO HAVE ONE QUESTION WHICH IS --
HOW DO YOU PERCEIVE THIS AS
DIFFERENT FROM CAP AND TRADE?
IN IN TERMS OF HOW DO WE HOW
WOULD WE HOW WOULD WE PROTECT
OURSELVES SO THE CAP AND TRADE
IS DOING ONE THING AND AND THIS
IS DOING SOMETHING ELSE OR MAYBE
THEY'RE SYNERGISTIC.
AND YOU HAVE A OPINION ON THAT.
WHAT WE DO USE CAP AND TRADE
FUNDING ON A LIMITED BASIS RIGHT
NOW FOR A CLAIM IS SPECIFIC FOR
CLIMB ADAPTATION ACTIVITY RIGHT
MOSTLY WITH THE FOR THE --
COASTAL COMMISSION -- THE
CONSERVANCY AND THE THE AND SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AT FORTY AND SO --
THEY'RE MOSTLY WORKING ON
CLIMATE -- LEVEL OF FACTS IN
PLANNING AND AND SOME PROJECTS
ALONG THE COAST -- IN TERMS OF
HOW BONDS CAN BE USE VERSES CAP
AND TRADE I THINK THEY THEY BOTH
CAN BE USED FOR CLIMATE AT
ADAPTATION ACTIVITIES I I
WOULDN'T BE THEM IN MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE.
YOU MIGHT THINK IF IF YOU ARE
FOR EXAMPLE THINKING ABOUT A
LONGER TERM BROADER STRATEGY FOR
CLIMATE ADAPTATION.
THERE MAY BE REASON TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT WE WANT TO USE BONDS
FOR THOSE LONGER TERM PROJECTS
AND PERHAPS YOU'D WANT TO USE
CAP AND TRADE FOR A DIFFERENT
SET OF PROJECTS -- A IF YOU WANT
IF YOU NEEDED TO DO MORE
PLANNING YOU WOULDN'T REALLY
WHEN YOU BOUGHT IT FOR HIM TO
EXTRACT IT HE'S PLANNING
ACTIVITY YOU MAY KNOW WHEN USED.
YOUR BOND MONEY FOR THAT THAT
MIGHT BE MORE APPROPRIATE USE
FOR CAP AND TRADE FUNDING BUT
THERE'S NO REASON -- THAT I'M
AWARE F THE CAP AND TRADE WOULD
BE AN INAPPROPRIATE USE FOR
ADAPTATION ACTIVITIES.
THANK YOU OTHERS QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
THE NINE DID.
I CAN OPEN UP FOR A PUBLIC
COMMENT IF YOU CAN STICK OR WELL
ENOUGH TO STICK AROUND YOU DID
YOU DID YOUR SERVICE BUT WILL
HOPE TO HEAR BACK FROM YOU AND
AND FOLLOW UP ON CENTER
CABALLERO AND TURNER MUNNINGS
THREADS AS WELL IN TERMS OF
DRILLING DOWN AND IF.
YOU TRY TO PRIMARY COST DRIVERS.
WE'RE LOOKING AT ARE LIKE REALLY
TRIED GET GRANULAR AS MUCH AS WE
CAN BUT THE LIABILITY INSERTED
SOLUTION SETS TO DO THAT.
I I APPRECIATE THE POINT ABOUT
CARBON PRICING VERSES BOND --
APPROACHES SO -- WRESTLE WITH
THAT ONE I'VE PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANKS PAUL MASON PACIFIC FOREST
TRUST AND I ACTUALLY WANTED --
TO BECOME TO THE I'M AT THE
SERVER CABALLERO JUST MADE SORT
OF YOU KNOW WE DO MAKE SOME OF
THESE INVESTMENTS WITH FOR
EXAMPLE THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND I'M THINKING OF
FOR EXAMPLE THE FOREST HEALTH
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE COMMITTED
TO MAKING OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS.
ONE THING THAT'S ALWAYS A
CHALLENGE WITH BOND FUNDING WENT
OVER LAPS AND SERVE ISSUE AREA
THERE WOULD BE OVERLAP BETWEEN I
THINK ANY.
SORT OF CLIMATE BOND AND MAKING
SOME WATER SAID AND FOR US NOT
TO RESOURCE OF INVESTMENTS AND
THOSE SORT OF ALL OTHER TO
EUROPE INVESTMENTS IS MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT SUPPLANTING.
INVESTMENTS WE OTHERWISE WOULD
BE MAKING.
WEATHERBY FROM GENERAL FUND OR
G. G. R. F. WITH THIS BOND MONEY
BECAUSE THEN WE'RE NOT REALLY
GETTING THAT ADDITIONAL --
PROGRESS TOWARDS THE CHALLENGE
WHICH IS A STAGGERING CHALLENGE
IN FRONT OF US MAKERS ARE THAT
AS WE'RE BORROWING MONEY TO DO
THESE THINGS ARE ACTUALLY
GETTING ADDITIONAL BENEFITS AND
THAT'S SOMETHING.
THAT THE STATE HAS STRUGGLED
WITH MANY TIMES IN THE PAST YOU
KNOW USING BOND MONEY TO FILL
BUDGET CHALLENGES AND IT'S
REALLY IT'S SICKENING IS NOT
REALLY ACHIEVING.
THE GOALS THAT WERE PRESENTED TO
THE VOTERS WHEN THEY PROVE THESE
THINGS.
THANKS.
WITHOUT FURTHER DO DID WE WANT
TO CLOSE THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ITEM AND HAVE CENTER ON
PRESENT -- YES SO LET'S LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND THEN
WE'LL -- WE'LL SHIP SO -- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SENATE STERN STERN
HERE JONES.
JONES HERE ALAN.
ALLEN HERE BURGESS.
BURGESS HERE CABALLERO.
CABALLERO PRESENT HERTZBERG
HUESO.
HUESO HERE JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY IN HERE.
VERY GOOD OF COURSE STATUS
COMMITTEES CONVENED AND GO IN --
FILE ORDER HERE SO -- CENTER
ALLEN SB.
FORTY FIVE WELL THERE IS A
MISMATCH MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND I DO ALSO APPRECIATE
THE PRESENTATION FROM THE LA --
THAT I THINK HELP HELPS THE
FAMILY SOME OF THE ASPECTS OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE I
ALSO ALSO OF COURSE WANT TO
EXTEND MY GRATITUDE THANKS TO
THE FOLKS FROM THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH
MY STAFF AND ON ON VARIOUS
ASPECTS OF THIS MEASURE AND I AM.
VERY HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE OUTLINED IN
THE ANALYSIS.
NOW IS THE HOUSES POINTS OUT
THIS BILL SB FORTY FIVE IS A
WORK IN PROGRESS AND WE REMAIN
VERY COMMITTED TO CONTINUING.
THE ON GOING WORK -- WITH BOTH
THE COMMITTEE AND ALSO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- AS TO THIS BILL MOVE
FORWARD TODAY.
THE IDEA OF THIS BILL IS THAT IF
IF THIS PASSED BY THE VOTERS.
SB FORTY FIVE WILL IT WOULD FIND
ON THE GROUND PROJECTS DESIGNED
TO HELP US PREPARE FOR THE
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS.
AND OTHER IMPACTS THAT WE'RE
SEEING AS A RESULT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE -- AND AS A RESULT OF OF
ALL OF OUR CHANGING ENVIRONMENT.
WILDFIRES FLOODS AND MUDSLIDES
DROUGHTS IT CENTER -- WE'RE
LIVING IN A WORLD TODAY THAT HAS
WORN BY JUST ONE DEGREE SINCE
THE EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS WHEN
RECORDS -- BEGAN ON A GLOBAL
SCALE.
AND THAT MEANS THAT THE FIRES
MUDSLIDES ARE PROLONGED DROUGHT
OR SEVERE WEATHERS -- STORMS ARE
ALL A RESULT OF A CHANGE OF JUST
ONE DEGREE CELSIUS BUT THE SAD
TRUTH IS.
THAT -- WE KNOW THAT THE LEASES
SCIENTISTS ARE TELLING US THAT --
THE INCREASES ARE GOING TO BE
QUITE A BIT MORE SIGNIFICANT THE
GOAL OF THE GLOBAL PARIS CLIMATE.
AGREEMENT WAS TO KEEP THE
WORLD'S TEMPERATURE FROM RISING
MORE THAN TWO DEGREES CELSIUS
OVER PRE INDUSTRIAL TIMES BUT
THE AGREEMENTS MORE AMBITIOUS
GOALS -- WAS TO PREVENT
TEMPERATURES ARE RISING MORE
THAN ONE POINT FIVE DEGREES.
CELSIUS AND THAT'S BECAUSE EVEN
ONE POINT FIVE DEGREES OF
WARMING WILL CAUSE CATASTROPHIC
EFFECTS INCLUDING MORE INTENSE
STORMS.
HEARING HE WEIGHS MASS
EXTINCTIONS DROUGHTS ETCETERA.
AND IF WE HAD TWO DEGREES THE
EFFECTS WILL BE EVEN WORSE.
NOW THAT THE TRUTH IS THAT WE
ACTUALLY KNOW THAT WE'RE ON
TRACK RIGHT NOW TO SEE MORE THAN
THREE PER THREE DEGREES OF
INCREASED ABOVE PREINDUSTRIAL
LEVELS BY. TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
ESPECIALLY SINCE WE'RE NOT ON
TRACK OUT TOWARD THE SCHOOL SO
THE POINT IS.
WE WE ARE WE'RE FIGHTING AGAINST
THE WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO
MITIGATE AND AND AND AND REDUCE
OUR ROLE IN CONTRIBUTING TO
CLIMATE CHANGE BUT WE ALSO NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THE CLIMATE CHANGE
IS HAPPENING.
WE SEE IN THE IMPACTS OF ALL
ALREADY AND WE NEED TO HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE TO
PROTECT AGAINST -- THE IMPACTS
AND BE MORE RESILIENT.
AND SO -- WHAT THIS MEASURED
SEEKS TO DO IS REDUCE FIRE
RESCUE AND RESTORE ALREADY
DAMAGED AREAS A RESTORED PROTECT
IMPACTED WETLANDS WATERSHEDS
WATERWAYS?
COASTAL RESOURCES FISH AND
WILDLIFE POPULATIONS REDUCE
IMPACTS AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AND ON VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
AND IMPROVE THE RESILIENCY OF
THE STATE'S WATER SUPPLIES AND
AGRICULTURAL LANDS.
NO ONE LIKE PREVIOUS BOND
MEASURES TO FIND PARKS AND OPEN
SPACE ALL THINGS THAT WE SUPPORT --
THIS BOND IS FOCUSED ON HELPING
OUR STATE BECOME MORE RESILIENT
TO RISING TEMPERATURES AND TO
ENSURE THAT WERE ABLE TO ADAPT.
TO A CHANGING CLIMATE THAT'S THE
FOCUS HERE SO DEDICATES A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FUNDING TO
THE FIRE ISSUES THAT WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING IT WILL -- FUND
PROJECTS THAT WILL REDUCE FIRE
RISK IN YOUR CMMUNITIES AND
ENSURE A FORCE ARE HEALTHY
ENOUGH TO WITHSTAND MORE INTENSE
WILDFIRES.
ARE THERE OTHER POTS THAT INVEST
IN PROJECTS THAT WILL REDUCE THE
RISK OF CATASTROPHIC FLOOD
EVENTS BY SLOWING RUNOFF
IMPROVING GROUND WATER
INFILTRATION.
AND PROTECTING COASTAL
COMMUNITIES FROM SEA LEVEL RISE.
SO THERE IS A THERE ARE NUMBER
OF OF DIFFERENT THINGS WE CAN
OPEN UP THIS DISCUSSION -- BUT
YOU KNOW THE FACT IS THAT WHEN
WE HAD OUR INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ON THE NEW ABNORMAL IN FIRE
PRONE REGIONS WE HEARD THE
REGION NINE ADMINISTRATOR FOR
FEMA SAY VERY EXPLICITLY THAT
FOR EVERY DOLLAR INVESTED IN
PREVENTION WE CAN SAVE SIX
DOLLARS.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE WE MUST TAKE AGGRESSIVE
ACTION.
AT IN IN MITIGATING THE IMPACT
IN INCREASING OUR RESILIENCY AND
I HAVE WITH ME JOE HAD MISSING
FOR THE NONCE RECREATION --
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY AND ALSO
I MEAN I TIGHTLY WHO'S THE EAST
BAY REGIONAL PARKS DISTRICT FIRE
CHIEF.
WHO ARE BOTH HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL?
GOOD WELCOME.
MISREPRESENT.
THE GERMAN MEMBERS AT JOE
WITNESSED AN EXECUTIVE OFFICER
THE MOUNT RECREATION
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY WHICH IS
A JOINT POWERS BETWEEN THE SANTA
MONICA MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY AND
OUR RECREATION AND PARK DISTRICT
PARTNERS.
IN THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS --
THE LA -- WAS VERY RESTRAINED AS
THEY ALWAYS ARE.
VERY -- AND CLICK CLICK CLICK.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE RESTRAINED
MISTER CHAIRMAN BECAUSE I COME
FROM YOUR DISTRICT.
A THIRD YOUR DISTRICT BURNED
LAST YEAR.
ALMOST 50% OF THE REST IS IN
DANGER.
WE'RE LOOKING AT FLASH EQUALS.
IT WAS WONDERFUL TO SEE THOSE
BEAUTIFUL WILD FLOWERS IT WAS
WONDERFUL SHE THE ALL THE GREEN
GRASS.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT IS WE CALL
THAT.
CAN GOING [inaudible]
IT'S KINDLING.
AND THERE'S NO GUARANTEE WE'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER
DROUGHT SUMMER.
AND TWO YEARS AGO THREE YEARS
AGO I REMEMBER EVERYONE WAS
SAYING YOU KNOW THESE ARE
EXTRAORDINARY SITUATIONS WE HAVE
HERE WE COME I HAVEN'T SEEN THAT
BEFORE.
AND THEN THE YEAR AFTER THAT IT
WAS -- WE INTERESTING WE'RE
SEEING IT NOW TWICE IN A ROW.
AFTER LAST YEAR WE CANNOT SAY.
WELL MAYBE THINGS WILL GET
BETTER.
I THINK THE BETTER ARGUMENT IS
THEY'RE PROBABLY GOING TO GET
WORSE.
AN EVEN IF THIS BILL IS PASSED
AND IF IT IS EVEN IF IT IS
PASSED IN MARCH.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO HEAR IS
BEFORE THIS MONEY CAN ACTUALLY
GET OUT AND DO SOME GOOD.
SO WE FOR AIMING TO DEAL WITH AN
EMERGENCY SITUATION WHICH I
THINK WE ARE MISTER CHAIRMAN IN
YOUR DISTRICT AND WE'RE GOING TO
BE WORKING WITH YOU TO SEE WHAT
WE CAN DO.
IMMEDIATELY WE GOT TWO YEARS
WORTH OF DANGER.
AND THIS IS TRUE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO THIS IS NOT SOMETHING WHICH
IS ACADEMIC THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DECIDE
WHETHER WE'RE GOING TO BALANCE
TWENTY YEARS FORTY YEARS
WHATEVER IT IS.
TELL THAT TO PEOPLE.
WHO ILL COME BACK TO THIS
LEGISLATURE AND SAY YOU HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY YOU HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE CHANGE TO
MAKE THINGS BETTER TO ADAPT
CALIFORNIA?
IF YOU ANSWER TO THEM WE TRIED
OUR BEST WONDERFUL IF YOU
ANSWERED WELL WE DIDN'T
[inaudible]
F. SAID.
I CHIEF.
AGAIN MY NAME IS EILEEN TIGHTLY
I AM THE FIRE CHIEF EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT THAT WE
WERE FOUND IN NINETEEN THIRTY
FOUR FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO MAY
NOT KNOW WHERE THE LARGEST LOCAL
PARK.
DISTRICT OR AGENCY IN THE NATION --
WE OPERATE OVER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND ACRES.
AND WE SERVE TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION RESIDENTS IN ALAMEDA AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
SO WE ALSO ENJOY ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE MILLION VISITORS A YEAR.
I AM MY FIRE DEPARTMENT WAS THE
WAS ONE OF THE FIRST RESPONDERS
TO THE NINETEEN NINETY ONE
TUNNEL FIRE WE CALL IT WHETHER
THE MEDIA CALL THE OAKLAND HILLS
FIRE.
AND IN THAT FIRE IT'S IMPORTANT
TO REMEMBER THAT IT WAS THREE
THOUSAND HOMES THAT WERE LOST
ONLY THREE THOUSAND HOMES THAT
WERE LOST YOU COULD SAY NOW.
AND AT TWENTY SIX PEOPLE LOST
THEIR LIVES.
WHAT THAT REALLY DID FOR THE
PARK DISTRICT WAS -- AS A LARGE
LAND MANAGEMENT AGENCY IS -- TO
CALL US TO FOCUS ON RESILIENT
FIRE PROTECTION AS AS ALMOST A
MORAL MANDATE.
SO AS A LARGE LAND MANAGEMENT
AGENCY WE UNDERSTAND THE
NECESSARY THE NECESSITY BETWEEN
STEWARDSHIP OF THE LAND AND ALSO
FORCE MANAGEMENT.
WE FOUND IN OUR PRACTICES THAT
EQUALS RESILIENCY WE'RE NOT
SAYING THAT WE CAN STOP A FIRE
FROM HAPPENING ON OUR LANDS BUT
WE ARE SAYING THAT WITH
STEWARDSHIP AND FORCE MANAGEMENT.
WE CAN MAKE OUR FORESTS -- IN
OUR WILD AND URBAN INTERFACE IS
MORE RESILIENT THE FIRES IN
THERE FOR AMERICA MORE
SURVIVABLE -- SO AT THAT POINT
WE HAVE ENTERED INTO A LONG TERM
UNDERSTANDING COMMITMENT REALLY
TO HEALTHY FORESTS.
WITH THAT COMMITMENT CAME A WILD
FIRE HAZARD REDUCTION AND
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT PLAN THAT
OUR BOARD SIGNED -- IN TWENTY
TEN AND WE ONLY RECENTLY GOT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CLEARANCE TO
ACTUALLY SPEND THOSE MONIES.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I GUESS
THE MESSAGE WE WANT TO SEND IS
THAT THE THE CLOCK IS REALLY
TAKING DEMAND.
WILL INCREASE AND ACCELERATE.
AS CLIMATE CHANGE -- CONTINUES.
TO BE HERE THE NEED IS URGENT.
A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THAT WAS LAST
YEAR FOR THIRTEEN DAYS SOLID --
IN THE BAY AREA IT'S GOT OVER
TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION PEOPLE
OF THOSE JUST THE THE RESIDENTS
THAT LIVE WITHIN ALAMEDA AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
WE HAD THE WORST AIR QUALITY IN
THE WORLD BECAUSE OF THE
CAMPFIRE -- WORSE THAN BEIJING
AND IT SHUT DOWN SCHOOLS FOR
LONG PERIODS OF TIME AND ALSO A
LOT OF BUSINESSES AND AND I'M
SURE -- WAS VERY SIGNIFICANT --
ECONOMICALLY -- A BONDS OF THIS
OF THIS NATURE WOULD REALLY
ACCELERATE THE WORK AND LEVERAGE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FROM CAL
FIRE FEMA HELLO YES.
AND WE'RE IN A RACE AT THIS
POINT.
CATASTROPHIC FIRES RELEASE MORE
CARBON EXACERBATING THE PACE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WE SAW THAT
AS AN EXAMPLE THAT I JUST GAVE
YOU OF OF THE THIRTEEN DAYS
WHERE PEOPLE WERE WEARING.
MASKS EVERY TIME THEY WENT
OUTSIDE.
THIS BOND MEASURE IS KIND OF A
FIRST RESPONDER TOOL -- IT'S
URGENT.
IT'S JUST ONE POLL TOOL THAT WE
CAN USE THE TOOL BOX -- LONG
TERM VEGETATION MANAGEMENT NEEDS.
REQUIRE FINANCIAL RESOURCES AND
STATEWIDE COMMITMENTS.
AND SENATOR ALLEN'S BOND MEASURE
STARTS A CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
KAUFMAN GERMAN STERN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE PROMISE OF THE
FOREST TRUST AGAIN.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS WORK FOR
DECADES NOW AND I'D SAY THE
THING THAT SCARES ME MORE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE IS THE LACK OF
URGENCY.
THAT WE'VE SEEN AROUND ADAPTING
TO THE INEVITABLE AFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT HOW IT'S GONNA GET A
LITTLE BIT WARMER A LITTLE BIT
DRIER TWO DEGREES AT ALL SEEMS A
CONCEPTUALLY MANAGEABLE.
AND THAT'S GONNA BE BAD BUT IS
THE EXTREME EVENTS THAT ARE
REALLY GOING TO BE DEVASTATING
THOSE YOU KNOW ATMOSPHERIC
RIVERS AT THIS PARK AND DROPPING
ALL TWO FEET OF WATER IN A
WATERSHED OVER A COUPLE OF DAYS.
THOSE ARE WHERE WE ARE SO FAR
BEHIND THE CURVE OFGETTING
PREPARED.
DO WE REALLY NEED TO JUMP START
THOSE ACTIVITIES TO DO THE
THINGS IN WHAT AROUND
COMMUNITIES AND UPLAND
WATERSHEDS WHERE WE CAN SLOW
THAT RUN OFF AND MAKE SURE WE'RE
NOT GETTING DEVASTATING FLOODS
COMING DOWN INTO TOWN.
AND BEING BETTER PREPARED FOR
FIRES SO SB FORTY FIVE IS THAT
JUMP START THAT WE NEED THANK
YOU SIR. FOR THE WITNESS IS
TESTIFYING IF YOU IF YOU HAVE A
QUICK POINT.
PLEASE MAKE IT.
BUT IF YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD IT
MADE THAN A ME TOO WILL BE FINE
BUT I KNOW WE'VE GOT A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS HERE SO.
LET'S TRY.
TO KEEP THE DIALOGUE.
JUST A SEQUENTIAL IF WE CAN IN
SOME WAY ADD YOUR POINT TO IT
THANK YOU ALI MARTINEZ
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GERLING WITH DUCKS UNLIMITED --
THE WORLD'S LEADER IN WETLANDS
CONSERVATION WETLANDS ARE THE
MOST BIOLOGICALLY DIVERSE
ECOSYSTEMS IN NORTH AMERICA SO
THIS THIS MEASURE WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL TOWARDS ANSWER THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DENNY ALLAN SHOT IN
BEHALF OF COMMUNITY NATURE
CONNECTION FRIENDS THE LA RIVER
ONLY NEIGHBORHOOD LAND TRUST IN
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS IS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
CENTERS LUCAS FOR ERIC SOME
BEHALF THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU CENTER.
THE MORNING JUST MULIN FOR HEAL
THE BAY STRONG SUPPORTER.
GOOD MORNING MARK SMITH ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
SPORTFISHING ASSOCIATION IN
CONCEPTUAL SUPPORT AS THE BOND
CONTINUES TO BE DEVELOPED THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
BEST SMOKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FOOD AND FARMING NETWORK IN
SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD THANKS GOOD MORNING
JAMIE GO ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
SUPPORT.
CAN CHAMBER HAVE A SNOWMAN UP
SPACE IN CINEMA WATER IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANKS.
MADELINE COOPER ON BEHALF OF
MARIN COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
TOM TELL CROWN BEHALF THE
PENINSULA OPEN SPACE TRUST AND%
SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACES
FORTY IN SUPPORT ALSO THE HAVE
THE PLANNING CONSERVATION LEAGUE
AND SPORT THANK YOU.
SIR.
AMANDA DEMARCO ON BEHALF OF THE
VIOLENCE CONSERVANCY AND THE
CALIFORNIA INVASIVE PLANT
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
THANKS A GOOD MORNING LUIS
BLOOMBERG ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES BASED CLIMATE RESOLVE.
I WANT TO POINT OUT TO POINTS
HERE ONE IS THAT THIS BOND IS
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THE BECAUSE
IT WILL PROVIDE FUNDING. TO
IMPLEMENT MANY THE POLICIES OF
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY
ADOPTED OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS
THROUGH A SERIES OF OF LAWS AND
REGULATIONS AND THE SECOND POINT
IS WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF.
TO TO BEEF UP AND EXPAND THE
BOND WE THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
POTENTIAL TO REALLY EXPAND THAT
IT.
AND BUILD A MORE ROBUST PROGRAM
IN THE URBAN ARENA THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MORNING SURE MEMBERS RECALL
MUSTER TO NOT A WITH THE TRUST
FOR PUBLIC LAND.
I REALLY APPRECIATE MISTER
MASON'S COMMENTS ON URGENCY
WE'VE HAD THE G. G. R. I. ZEROED
OUT FOR EVERY NATURAL RESOURCE
PROGRAM THE LAST TWO YEARS
EXCEPT.
FOREST HEALTH.
AND THOSE ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS
THAT HE TALKED ABOUT FALLING ON
WATERSHED THEY'RE GONNA FALL ON
URBAN AREAS PRETTY SOON AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE HEAT ISLANDS
THAT ARE GOING TO SIT THERE.
AND WE'RE NOT PREPARED FOR THAT
AND IT DOESN'T SEEM THAT THERE
IS URGENCY WE ABSOLUTELY
DESPERATELY NEEDS URBAN
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE AND ON AS
BE.
FORTY FIVE BUT WE IT SHOULDN'T
SUPPLANT.
WHAT WE CAN DO WITH THE TEACHER
R. F. BECAUSE WE CAN SPEND THAT
NEXT YEAR NOT TWO YEARS FOR AN A
OR THREE YEARS FROM NOW?
SO -- IN STRONG SUPPORT REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR BILL.
GOOD MORNING SERRA STREAMER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
OFFERS ALL AUTHORS OFFICE ON
AMENDMENT FOR AND IF THAT IS
CHANGE THAT WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MORNING SURE MEMBERS CHRIS
MARTIN'S HERE BEHALF THIS YEAR
BUSINESS COUNCIL AS WELL AS A
COALITION OF SIERRA BASE WHEN
TRUSTS AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS.
SB SEE ALSO RUNS THE REGIONAL
CLIMATE COLLABORATIVE FOR THIS
YEAR AND THAT OUR REGION HAS
WERE ESPECIALLY SUPPORT OF A
CHAPTER TWELVE WHICH RECOGNIZES
THE REGIONAL APPROACH TO CLIMATE
ADAPTATION ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
MORNING MR CHAIR MARK FENCE
MAKER FOR THE BALL STRUCK A LAND
TRUST IN THE BIG SUR LAND TRUST
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
CENTER ALLEN FIRST CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP AND YOUR LEADERSHIP
MISTER CHAIR ON THIS VERY
PRESSING ISSUE THANK YOU.
HELLO KILLER ROBINSON HERE ON
BEHALF OF OCEAN CONSERVANCY
CALIFORNIA TROUT MAINTENANCE OF
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT AND
AS CAN GET OKAY CONSERVANCY HERE
IN SUPPORT.
THANKS.
HI NATALIE MAX HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANNING COALITION ATLANTA SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY THE GONNA GREEN
ABOUT ENDANGERED HABITATS LAKE
AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE WHILE
THE QUARTER WORKING GROUP AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHEN REBEKAH MARKETS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATEIN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK A COALITION
OF THE STATE'S LEADING
SUSTAINABLE AND ORGANIC
AGRICULTURE ORGANIZATIONS WE
SUPPORT WITH AMENDMENTS SB?
FORTY FIVE IT IS AN IMPORTANT
EFFORT TO ADDRESS THE THREAT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IS ALREADY
IMPACTING FARMERS BUT AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED THE BILL FONG
THE BOND.
FAILS TO INVEST ADEQUATELY IN
OUR FOOD SYSTEM AN AGRICULTURAL
RESILIENCE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND ONLY SERVER -- DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JENNIFER CLARY CLEAN WATER
ACTION WITH SUBMITTED A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED LETTER BUT
AFTER A RECENT AMENDMENTS IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH AUTHORS OFFICE
WERE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
DEBBIE YOURS WITH ME WATER
CENTER AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTIN
ACCOUNTABILITY ALL ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CLEAN MORE ACTION WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE NEED FOR GREATER
INVESTMENT IN CLIMB IN WATER
RESILIENCY AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORKING WITH AUTHOR.
DENTURE THE MOST HORRIBLE
COMMUTERS ARE INCLUDED THANK YOU.
MORNING MR CARE MEMBERS DOCUSIGN
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA PARK
AND RECREATION SOCIETY
CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR RECREATION
PARTNERS -- SAVE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE.
CINEMA COUNTY REGIONAL PARKS
TH<c.cyan> CITY P. U. D..</c>
AND WATERSHED CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY FOR ALL SUPPORT X.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS PATRON WITH THEIR AND
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY
IN OPPOSITION.
THIS INVOLVES SEEING NINE
MEMBERS QUESTIONS COMMENTS A
CEREMONY IN IN THIS CENTER
CAREER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I WANT TO THINK THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
THINK THE EARLIER.
LA -- PRESENTATION WAS.
COMPLIMENTARY.
TO THE THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
SIN INDEED THE EXTREME
IMPORTANCE GIVEN WHAT WE'RE UP
AGAINST I HAD JUST A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS -- WITH FOCUS ON SEA
LEVEL RISE RESILIENCY ADAPTATION
I KNOW COASTAL CONSERVANCY'S
IDENTIFIED HERE BUT NOTHING FOR
THE OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL
WOULD YOU CONSIDER THE OPC TO
HAVE ANY.
ROLL I THINK WE OFTEN GET TO OUR
SHORELINE BUT WE DON'T LOOK AT
HOW OCEAN HEALTH IS AFFECTING.
THESE DYNAMICS IN IS.
WE ARE CONNECTED AND I WOULD
JUST ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER.
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL IS
POSSIBLY CONTRIBUTING. TO THE
RESILIENCE AN ADAPTATION -- AND
THEN ALSO JUST TO A MORE GENERAL
QUESTION.
IS THERE ANY METRIC THE YEAR
WHERE EVER THAT WE COULD LOOK.
FOR THAT WOULD LOOK AT HOW
INVESTMENT DOLLARS MOST DIRECTLY.
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH IN OTHER
WORDS -- WRIT LARGE CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS PUBLIC HEALTH BUT
IN TERMS OF OUR INVESTMENTS.
THERE MAY BE SOME THAT MORE
IMMEDIATELY PROTECT COMMUNITIES
AT RISK.
WHETHER IT'S AIR POLLUTION --
OTHER THAN THAT HAVE A A
TRACEABLE IN CURRENTLY KNOWN
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVERSE IMPACTS SO.
I DON'T KNOW THAT YOU HAVE I'M
NOT REALLY ASKING FOR AN ANSWER
RIGHT NOW IT JUST SAYS THAT --
AS WE A PORTION INVESTMENT.
LET'S DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH ASSN AT
RISK COMMUNITIES.
THEY BOTH FANTASTIC SUGGESTS
ACTUALLY SERVE ON THE OCEAN
PACIFIC COUNCIL SO -- I'M BY
IT'S A GREAT SUGGESTION WELL TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO INCORPORATE
THEM IN AYE AYE I LOVE YOUR IDEA
ABOUT.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH METRICS YOU
DESERVE PARTICULAR GOOD WHEN THE
YOU.
NOT THAT I'M AWARE OF ALTHOUGH
WE COULD ACCESS EXISTING
RESOURCES WHETHER SALIH OR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
OR WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
CATEGORIES OF INVESTMENT SOME
MAY HAVE A MORE IMMEDIATE
BENEFIT TO AIR QUALITY AND OR I
MEAN LSS OF PROPERTIES THROW
FIRE RISK YES MEDIA PUBLIC
HEALTH.
RISKS BUT AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
ON IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD CENTER HAVE YEAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I ALSO WANTED -- AB BRIEFER
STARTING IN INTERESTING
DISCUSSION.
BECAUSE I THINK I AM I THINK
THERE'S SOME SOME GREAT
OPPORTUNITIES HERE RIGHT.
I ALSO WANNA I'D LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THIS -- PARTICULARLY
AS IT RELATES TO RURAL
CALIFORNIA -- I THINK THERE'S
SOME CLIMATE CHANGE CHANGE BY
PRODUCTS THAT ARE -- FAIRLY
SIGNIFICANT THAT WE REALLY
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT -- ONE IS
THE POTENTIAL FOR FOOD SHORTAGES
SEARCH SHORTAGE JUDGE
METICULOUSLY -- AS IT RELATES TO
FEEDING OUR COUNTRY -- I'VE
ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT -- WAS THAT.
A NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE THAT
WE CONTROL OUR OWN FOOD SOURCE
BECAUSE THE MINUTE SOMEONE
DOESN'T LIKE US THAT ME.
REALLY IMPACT -- HOW WE GET OUR
FOOD AND IT'S BECOME MORE CLEAR
WITH THEIR -- WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
WERE ANGERING A BUNCH OF OUR
ALLIES AND THEY MAY NOT WANT TO
HELP US EAT -- IN THE FUTURE --
BUT ALSO IT WOULD THERE'S A
GREAT POTENTIAL -- FOR FOR THE
CONFLUENCE OF ISSUES STATION.
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON RURAL
RESIDENTS IN PARTICULAR BECAUSE
IF WE HAVE TO FOLLOW AND WE
DON'T HAVE A GOOD -- SOLUTION TO
WHAT THE WHAT WILL HAPPEN WITH
THAT LAND ALTERNATIVELY THAT WE
MAY END UP WITH DUST BOWL TYPE
OF MIGRATION PATTERNS THAT.
REALLY NOT DEVASTATOR RURAL
RURAL COMMUNITIES ECONOMIES BUT
ALSO MAKE PEOPLE MOVE -- FROM
WROTE CALIFORNIA AND LOSE ALL OF
THE ASSETS THAT THEY'VE INVESTED
THERE AS WELL SMALL FARMERS AS
WELL AS AS WHOLE WHOLE
COMMUNITIES -- SO I'D LIKE TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THAT SO THAT WE
CAN.
LOOK DOWN THE ROAD AND WE MEAN
NEED TO DO.
I MEAN WE TALKED ABOUT THIS IN
TERMS OF OF WHAT THE LA --
PRESENTED BUT WE MAY NEED TO DO
SOME MODELING SO WE CAN FIGURE
OUT WHERE ARE THE IMPACTS LIKELY
TO HIT FIRST -- AND HOW CAN WE
START CREATING THE OPPORTUNITIES
TO BE ABLE TO DO THINGS A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENTLY WHETHER IT'S
MOVE WATER WHETHER IT'S CREATE --
OTHER SOLUTIONS THEY'RE NOT ON
WERE EIGHTY GREAT IDEAS LED TO
WORK WITH YOU AND BY THE WAY I
CAN HELP AND NOTICE.
PART OF THE BIG DISCUSSION ABOUT
BREXIT RIGHT NOW IN THE U. K. IS
IS WHAT DISTRICT CREDIBLE
DISRUPTION.
THE BREAK AWAY FROM THE YOU WILL
COST TO THEIR FOOD CHAIN FOOD
SUPPLY BECAUSE THEY'VE BECOME SO
DEPENDENT ON GROWERS IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE FOR THE REGION AND
IT'S REALLY.
A MAJOR STICKING POINT.
SO THAT THAT'S A VERY
INSTRUCTIVE POINT [inaudible]
YEAH.
VERY GOOD SENATOR HUESO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND GOOD
MORNING I I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR TAKING UP THIS ISSUE IN
THAT IT ALREADY LOOKS LIKE YOU
PUT AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF WORK
INTO IT.
NOT AN EASY THING TO DO.
AND AND GETTING TO THE KIND OF
THE URGENCY OF THE MATTER I JUST
WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE BUDGETED.
ALMOST EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION TO
RESPOND FIRE SENT -- TO OF
BUTTRESS.
OUR OUR FIRE OF SERVICES IN OUR
STATE.
THAT'S THAT'S QUITE A BIT.
MORE MORE THAN.
MORE THAN I'VE EVER SEEN.
IN RECENT HISTORY AND THAT IS
DEFINITELY OUT OF CONCERN FOR
WHAT IS HAPPENING ACROSS THE
STATE.
AND THEN IF WE REALLY HAVE A
SENSE OF URGENCY ON THIS I I DO
THINK WE NEED TO DO MORE.
AS I REVIEWED THE BILL -- I WILL
I JUST WANT TO SHARE MY CONCERNS
OF THE YOU AND JUST WHAT WHAT
I'VE SEEN AND AND I'D LIKE US TO
REALLY RELY ON ON THE SCIENCE OF
HOW WE'RE GONNA.
BUT START TO ADDRESS.
THIS PROBLEM FACING OUR STATE
THE FIRES.
OF NOT ALL OF THE FIRE ISSUE --
THE THE FORCED ISSUE -- CLIMATE
pWE'VE BEEN PASS AND BILLS AND
WE'VE BEEN DOING OUR PART AND I
AND I THINK THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY FOR OVER
A DECADE. TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE AND TO ADDRESS OUR
QUALITY AND TO I DON'T DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY.
BUT I THINK WE'VE BEEN LEADERS
IN THE COUNTRY AND UNFORTUNATELY
OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S NOT
BACKING US UP.
IN EVERY AREA WHEN WE'VE NEEDED
HELP WITH -- MANAGING OUR
FORESTS EVEN FEDERALLY MANAGED
FORESTS THEY'RE NOT MANAGING.
DOING WHAT'S WITHIN CLEARLY
THERE THEIR AREA OF
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND SO WE ALMOST HAVE TO ACT
ALONE IN THIS BECAUSE I DON'T
SEE ANYTHING COMING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO HELP
CALIFORNIA AND UNFORTUNATELY WE
SUBSIDIZE THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY.
WITH OUR TAXES AND WE DON'T SEE
THOSE TAXES COME BACK TO OUR
STATE THAT'S JUST THE
UNFORTUNATE PART.
BUT IT WITH REGARD TO WHAT
YOU'RE PUTTING TOGETHER AND YOU
KNOW THEIR TESTS TO BE A
TENDENCY HERE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE WHAT I'VE SEEN WHAT
WHENEVER WE PUT TOGETHER SOME
KIND OF BOND.
OR SOME ON THE BUS SOLUTION TO A
PROBLEM THAT -- PEOPLE TEND TO
STICK IN THEIR PRIORITIES.
AND THAT JUST THAT THAT JUST
HAPPENS -- VERY ORGANICALLY HERE.
WHERE WHERE EVERYBODY JUST SAYS
WHAT ABOUT ME WHAT ABOUT MY
DISTRICT AND I GET THAT AND AND
AND I'M HERE TO TO FIGHT FOR MY
DISTRICT AS WELL [inaudible]
BUT I I'D LIKE TO SEE IS PUT
TOGETHER BOND THAT IS BASED ON
SCIENCE I MEAN THERE THERE ARE
NUMEROUS NEEDS ACROSS THE STATE.
BUT WHICH ONE IS GOING TO
MAXIMIZE OUR BOND DOLLAR BECAUSE
WOULDN'T WORK WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
INTO THE FUTURE RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE GETTING TO THAT POINT.
WHERE OUR STATE IS GOING TO BE
OVER LEVERAGE SOME BONDS WE'VE
DONE A LOT OF BONDS?
AND AND TO VOTER INITIATIVES
WE'VE DONE BONDS [inaudible]
AND AND THOSE BONDS ARE VERY
COSTLY.
AND IF WE SEE A DOWNTURN ARE
BUDGET WHICH IS WHERE WE'RE
APPROACHING THAT CYCLE WE'RE
GOING TO SEE OUR OUR OUR OUR
REVENUES GO DOWN SHARPLY LIKE
THEY DID IN. 220-009-2000.
TEN OUR OUR DEBT.
IN PROPORTION TO OUR REVENUE.
RIGHT NOW IS IS PRETTY AVERAGE.
BUT IN A DOWNTURN THAT THAT
THAT'S GONNA THE PROPORTIONS CAN
INCREASE SHARPLY.
ANY REDUCTION.
IN IN OUR REVENUE IS GONNA MEAN.
A DISPROPORTIONATE INCREASE IN
ON TERMS OF THAT THE BURKE RATIO
WE HAVE TO BE VERY.
CAREFUL TO THAT HE IS MINDFUL OF
THAT INCLUDING PUTTING IN SOME
KIND OF MECHANISM. TO ALLOW
EITHER THROUGH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE FOR THE LEGISLATURE. TO
TO NOT ISSUE A BOND.
IN CASE OF EXTREME HARDSHIP.
AND AND AND HAVING SOME KIND OF
TRIGGER THAT ALLOWS US TO TO
FOREGO THAT THERE ARE STE THERE
ARE SEVERAL THINGS THAT SHOULD
SHOULD -- ALLOW US TO MANAGE OUR
FINANCES ONE INCLUDING IN.
OUR IN OUR CREDIT RATING AND
WHAT THAT MEANS TO INTEREST
RATES -- AND ANOTHER IS WHAT
WHAT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE ARE
BUDGET GOES DOWN ARE WE TIED TO
HAVE INITIALLY.
HAVING TO ISSUE BONDS AND IT AND
IT MAY BE SOMETHING THAT MEET
MAY BECOME A NECESSITY BUT WE
NEED TO HAVE -- THAT RETAIN THAT
DECISION MAKING POWER IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE SIDE SHOULD
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH.
ISSUE IN DEBT OR SHOULD WE CURB
THAT FOR NOW. TO TO BALANCE OUR
BUDGET THAT NEEDS TO BE
SOMETHING WE COULD CONSIDER BUT
GOING BACK TO THE SCIENCE.
YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW CURRENTLY
WHEN I READ I READ THIS I SEE
[inaudible]
THIS BOND.
AT ABOUT -- JUST UNDER FIVE
BILLION FOUR POINT.
THREE BILLION DOLLARS WERE
TRYING TO SOLVE EVERY PROBLEM.
I LOOK GO THROUGH THE LIST AND
WORK WERE DRESSING SAFE DRINKING
WATER.
WE'RE LOOKING AT GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT.
WE'RE LOOKING A STORM WATER
CAPTURE FOR ITS RESILIENCY OF
FOREST RESTORATION SEA LEVEL
RISE REDUCING.
THE WILD FIRE RISK FLOOD
MANAGEMENT PROTECTION.
OF PROTECTING FIH AND WILDLIFE
RESTORING IMPACTED WATER BODIES
ALL OF THOSE THINGS.
ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT WHAT IS OUR PRIORITY RIGHT
NOW AND IF WE ARE GOING TO GO TO
ISSUE IN THAT.
WHAT IS IT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
FOCUS ON A RE GONNA FOCUS ON
MAKING OUR STATE MORE RESILIENT
TO WILDFIRES?
OR WE GONNA OR WE GONNA.
SOLVE EVERY OTHER PROBLEM.
ALONG WITH THAT AND REALLY NOT
DO EITHER.
MAYBE MAYBE THIS WILL HELP US TO
A LITTLE BIT OF EVERYTHING.
BUT IS THAT WHAT WE NEED RIGHT
NOW.
RIGHT NOW SHOULD WE BE
PRIORITIZING -- RESILIENCY I
THINK THE MESSAGE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE VOTERS ARE WE
WILL IF WE ARE GOING TO BOND.
IF WE ARE GOING TO GO DOWN THAT
ROUTE.
I THINK WE SHOULD.
FOCUS.
I THINK WE SHOULD DEVELOP A PLAN.
AND DEVELOP A VERY CLEAR
STRATEGY WHO'S GOING TO
IMPLEMENT THIS PLAN OR WE GONNA
HAVE VARIOUS AGENCIES WORKING
INDEPENDENTLY TO FOCUS ON THEIR
OWN ISSUES.
WHEN WE WILL WE DEVELOP SILOS IT
WEAKENS OUR ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT
OUR STRATEGY?
AND THAT'S THOSE ARE MY CONCERNS --
SENATOR.
AND AND I I I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU.
WITH YOU ON THIS I'D LOVE TO
COME UP.
WITH SOMETHING THAT THAT --
SERVES OUR STATE BUT HOPEFULLY
WILL DO THIS FROM LENDS.
BOB GOOD.
OF FISCAL PRUDENCE.
WITH WITH A FOCUS ON SOLVING.
THE BIGGEST THREATS TO OUR STATE.
OR FACING OUR STATE TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SIR HUESO CENTER
BORDERS.
THANK CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE MY
THE COMMENTS FROM -- MY MY
COLLEAGUE -- SENATOR HUESO IN
THE CENTER COVER EURO I THINK --
THEY BROUGHT OUT SOME ASSUME
SINCE SOME GOOD POINTS.
I'LL I BELIEVE IN SCIENCE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT OUR CLIMATE
HAS -- ON BEEN UNDERGOING
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE AND TO THINK
OTHERWISE I THINK IS PUTTING
YOUR HEAD IN THE SAND -- SO I'M
GONNA PUT THAT OUT THERE.
AT THE OUTSET -- I DO LIKE THE
IDEA OF BUILDING A STRATEGY.
BASED ON SCIENCE BASED ON
PRIORITIES.
SO I COMMEND -- YOUR YOUR
PROPOSAL ON THE EVE THAT YOU PUT
FORWARD FOR US TO KIND OF FIGURE
OUT WHAT'S WITH SUCH A LARGE
DOLLAR AMOUNT THAT -- THIS WOULD
BE A WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO DEVISE -- A COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY BASED ON THE INPUT OF
PERSONS MOST KNOWLEDGEABLE IN
THEIR RESPECTIVE FIELDS --
CREATING A LIST AND I THINK --
MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED THAT
EVERYONE OF US IS GOING TO SAY.
THIS IS A GREAT IDEA BUT LET'S
TALK ABOUT MY DISTRICT YOU KNOW
EVERY ONE OF US IS GOING TO HAVE --
A COMMONER -- TO LIKE THAT AND
I'M NO DIFFERENT -- I BELIEVE
THAT -- THE THE AREA THAT I
REPRESENT THE CENTRAL VALLEY --
IS GROUND ZERO WHEN IT COMES TO
AGRICULTURAL CHALLENGES WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE CHALLENGES SO ON
SO FORTH -- THAT'S WHY BEEN --
SUCH A STAUNCH SUPPORTER OF THE
A REQUEST FOR FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FRANKLIN CAN NOW.
SO I GUESS MY QUESTION TO TO TO
YOU -- CENTER ALLEN IS THAT.
AS THIS MOVES ALONG -- I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE IF THERE IS A WAY TO
DEVISE AN OVERARCHING STRATEGY --
FOR THE USE OF THESE DOLLARS --
IN HOW THE ITERCONNECTS TO GIVE
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS THAT WOULD
BE ALLOCATED CERTAIN AMOUNTS TO
ADMINISTER.
HOW DO THEY ALL RELATE BECAUSE
THERE ARE CERTAIN -- PROJECTS
THAT SHOULD HAVE HIGHER PRIORITY
BASED ON THE OBJECTIVE NEEDS OF
OF OF A GIVEN ISSUE.
SO WHAT AT WHAT POINT IN THIS
PROCESS WOULD SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
BE POSSIBLE DO YOU HAVE ANY
IDEAS.
WELL. TWO AND A EIGHT I THINK
YOU'RE BOTH OF THE QUESTIONS OF
A FASTENER WESTERN CENTER BOARD
JUST DOVETAIL NICELY -- I WILL
SAY THAT THE IF YOU LOOK AT THE
AMOUNTS THAT ARE -- THAT ARE
THAT ARE LAID OUT AND YOU CAN
SEE THAT THE THAT THE MAIN FOCUS
IS ON WILDFIRE RESILIENCY THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER ISSUES
THAT ARE RELATED AND AND AND AND
VITALLY IMPORTANT -- BUT THAT IT
REALLY IS AT THE THE CORE OF THE
THE BOND I WILL SAY THAT TO SOME
EXTENT THIS IS ALSO A RESPONSE.
TO THE FAILED ATTEMPTS -- THE
LAST ELECTION THAT IMPROPER --
THREE WHICH DID HAVE A NUMBER
WATER PROJECTS OTHER PROJECTS --
IT ROLLED INTO IT AND YET AND IF
YOU SEE IT IT DID WELL -- IT BUT
EVEN THOSE FOLKS WHO CAME OUT
SUPPORT.
DID SO VERY RELUCTANTLY THERE
WERE A LOT OF EDITORIAL BOARDS
IT REALLY -- OPENLY.
NOW WE'RE TORN ABOUT WHETHER TO
SUPPORTED NOT BECAUSE IT LOOKED
LIKE IT WAS SUCH A SUCH A
ENTREPRENEURIAL CHRISTMAS TREE --
AND IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
BASICALLY GETTING VARIOUS FOLKS
TO TO JOIN ON AND BE A PART OF
IT -- BECAUSE THEY KNEW THEY
WOULD GET THEIR LITTLE PIECE OF
PIPE BUT IT REALLY DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH OF A OVER ARCHING
STRATEGY BEHIND IT.
AND SO SO THESE ARE GREAT
QUESTIONS AND I THINK ULTIMATELY
IT IS GOING TO TAKE A LIKE A
SMART.
AND AND AND KIND OF THOUGHT FULL.
SENATE DIRECTION FROM FROM
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP AND AND
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE -- IF IT'S IF
IT'S IMPLEMENTED TO HELP. TO
BOTH DEAL WITH FISCAL PRUDENCE
ISSUES AND I THINK THAT WE
ABSOLUTE UP I KNOW IT BE BACK
YOU KNOW EIGHT OR NINE WE DIDN'T
ISSUE BONDS FOR EXAMPLE ON THE
NATURAL BECAUSE OF THE THE
DIFFICULT.
FINANCIAL CONDITIONS BUT I DO
THINK WE GOT TO PUT SOME STRONG
LANGUAGE IN THERE THAT ALLOWS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE AND THE AND
THE GOVERNOR TO ADD TO TO NOT
ISSUE BONDS WHEN IT.
JUST DOESN'T MAKE FINANCIAL
SENSE WE WE GOT WITH THAT WE
OUGHT NOT HAVE A A KIND OF A A
ROCK HARD.
YOU KNOW -- SET OF REQUIREMENTS
FOR ISSUANCE IT BECAUSE THERE'S
CERTAIN TIMES WHEN THE MARKET
CONDITIONS JUST DON'T LEND
THEMSELVES TO DOING SO -- SO
THAT THAT WE OUGHT TO PUT IN --
AND THEN AND THEN IN THE END OF
THE DAY THIS IS ABOUT.
I YOU KNOW MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S REAL COHERENCE AT THIS
AND THAT'S PART OF THIS
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND IT'S
ALSO GOING TO INVOLVE ME THIS
COMMITTEE IS A CRITICAL PART OF
THAT PROCESS RIGHT THIS IS WHERE
THERE'S EXPERTISE.
AND AND AND WORKING WITH OF
COUNTERPARTS THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
TO YOU KNOW MAKE SURE THAT THERE
REALLY IS A KIND OF A STRATEGY
ASSOCIATED WITH THE WAY THAT THE
THE BOND -- IS IS FORMULATED AND
AND IT'S A IT'S A BIT OF A DANCE
IS WE HAVE TO YOU KNOW GET.
POLITICAL SUPPORT NOT ONLY
WITHIN THIS BUILDING BUT THEN
OUT WITH THE VOTERS -- BUT PART
OF WHY I WANTED TO DO THIS WAS
BECAUSE I SAW WHAT HAPPENED PROP
THREE AND I SAW THE FACT THAT IT
WAS SO.
THAT PROCESS WAS SO PROBLEMATIC
AND AND I MEAN IT WOULD BE A
THIS THIS IS GOING TO BE HARD
ENOUGH TO COME MANAGE AND AND
WE'RE DOING THIS ALL TOGETHER AS
A AS A TEAM.
I THAT WAS A PARTICULARLY -- YOU
KNOW -- BE ENTREPRENEURIAL PROD
PROCESS THAT THAT I THOUGHT
TOO HAPHAZARD IN TERMS OF OF OF
ENGAGING PEOPLE AND NOT REALLY
HAPHAZARD IT WAS IT WAS A LITTLE
TOO OP IS MAYBE TO TRANSACTIONAL
PERHAPS.
AND SO I'M YOU GUYS ARE TOUCHING
ON ALL THE RIGHT QUESTIONS AND
IT'S PART OF WHAT GAVE ME PAUSE
WHEN I WAS CONSIDERING EVEN
PROPOSING THIS.
BECAUSE THESE GET BIG AND YOU
REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU BI<c.cyan> ULTIMATELY HAVE A</c>
REAL IMPACT BOTH ON PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ON RESILIENCY.
AND AND WE'VE TRIED TO CRAFTED
IN A WAY THAT.
IS COHERENT BUT BUT WE
ABSOLUTELY WELCOME THE THE THE
CONTINUAL ENGAGEMENT OF WHAT THE
COMMITTEE BUT EVERYONE OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THROUGH
THIS PROCESS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET IT
RIGHT I KNOW THAT'S A I I KNOW
THAT'S NOT IT'S BE SPECIFIC
ANSWER YOU'RE LOOKING FOR BUT
IT'S A HARD.
ONE TO HIS HEART YEAH SO HERE'S
MY UNABASHED PLUG FOR THE AREA
THAT I REPRESENT OKAY -- PART OF
THE PROBLEM SENATOR.
SO I THINK.
WE HAVE A CONFIDENCE ISSUE -- IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY -- ABOUT.
BEEN NICELY WORDED BONDS.
THAT -- ARE DESCRIPTIVE AND
EVERYONE CAN BUY INTO -- THE
APPROPRIATENESS OF THEIR PASSAGE.
AND WHAT HAPPENS IS -- WHEN THEY
GO TO A RESPECTIVE DEPARTMENT OR?
A BODY THAT IF MINISTERS THOSE
FUNDS.
THE SCIENCE GETS REALLY FUNNY.
AND I BELIEVE THAT SITE SHOULD
BE OUR OBJECTIVE IN IT SHOULD BE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE FAX.
BUT SOMETIMES INDIVIDUAL OR
AREAS THAT WERE EXPECTING TO
RECEIVE DOLLARS.
AND THIS GOES BACK TO WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE INTO WHETHER IT'S
TEMPERANCE WHETHER IT'S RECHARGE
BASINS ARE SO ON AND SO FORTH.
AND THERE IS CERTAIN REGIONS
JUST DON'T GET WHAT THEY'RE
PROMISED EVEN WITH THE WEEK AND
THEN DODD IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS SO YOU CAN KIND OF SEE
WHERE SOME OF THE FOLKS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY I WANT TO SPEAK
FOR CENTER COPIER BUT YOU MIGHT
VERY WELL AGREE -- SO THAT'S WHY.
I BECOME MORE OF A FAN OF
ARTICULATING THE RECIPIENTS.
AND THE THE AREAS IN THE WORDING
OF THE BOND SO WE CAN AVOID THE
AMBIGUITY OF OF OF WHAT THE REP
WITH THE RECIPIENT MIGHT BE IN
THE IN THE LONG TERM -- BECAUSE
WE HAVE A WAY OF JUST KIND OF
CHANGING THAT OUT.
WOULD YOU BE OPEN.
TO IF THERE WERE MASTER STRATEGY.
BEING MORE SPECIFIC IN THE
WORDING OF THE BOND WE'RE
RECIPIENT -- DOLLARS WOULD MOST
LIKELY GO.
IT'S A TRICKY THING SENATOR AYE
AYE AYE DOUBTS WE HEAR YOU I'D
LOVE TO GET A BETTER SENSE AND
OTHER.
MEN IF YOU WILL BE HAPPY TO SEE
IF YOU WANNA SAY IT NOW WHEN YOU
SAY THE SCIENCE GETS FUNNY CAN
YOU.
CLARIFY THAT A LITTLE BIT MORE
SO WE CAN UNDERSTAND A USE
TEMPERATE FLIGHT AS AN EXAMPLE.
THE NOTION.
OF THEM THE MODELING THAT WAS
USED TO DETERMINE -- WE'RE THE
WAS IT WAS A PROP.
ONE PROP ONE FUNDING WAS GOING
TO GO FOR WATER INFRASTRUCTURE --
THE MODELING THAT DETERMINE THAT
BENEFICIAL USE WAS ONE OF THE
METRICS.
AND IT WAS NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
STOMACH.
THE IDEA THAT.
THE AGRICULTURAL REAPER -- AREA
OF THE VALLEY AND TO THE THE
INDIVIDUALS -- IN THE RURAL
AREAS -- IN THE NEED FOR CLEAN
DRINKING WATER SO ON AND SO
FORTH WE'RE NOT VIEWED UPON AS A
BOB AND OFFICIALS USE OF COURSE.
BLEW OUR MINDS ARE EVEN THOUGH
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE
CLEARLY INVOLVED IN THE
SUCCESSFUL PASSAGE OF THAT --
WERE ANTICIPATING THAT -- THE
VALLEY WOULD WOULD BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE THAT
SO THAT I USE THAT AS AN EXAMPLE
THAT THE SCIENCE IS THERE BUT
THE MODELING HE TENDS TO HAVE
THE GOAL POST MOVE OVER TIME.
THAT ONE'S BEEN TOO MUCH TIME
YEAH NO I AM SO MAYBE A CASE
LIKE THAT MAYBE MAYBE WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT SPECIFICITY MAYBE
MAYBE THE ANSWER IS TO TO REALLY
PUT IN SPECIFICITY WITH REGARDS
TO CLEAN DRINKING WATER AND AND
YOU KNOW I'M AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY SO.
WE CAN USE THE GENERAL LANGUAGE
BUT STILL SPECIFIC ENOUGH TO BE
ABLE TO TO GET TO THE CORE OF
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS
YES SO IT ALL IT FINISHES
BECAUSE I KNOW OTHER PEOPLE. TO
THE SIX HUNDRED MILLION FOR
WATER SUPPLY AND WATER QUALITY --
BY LIKE THAT.
TYPE OF SPECIFICITY -- WITHIN
THAT.
DID YOU ENVISION OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE INTO THE
CONSERVANCY'S AT ALL THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
YEAH WE'RE NOT -- THAT'S
ELIGIBLE AT AHLERS AT NOT
INELIGIBLE USES TO BE SORT OF
OKAY TIME BY THAT I WILL FINISH
MY PLUG -- ON THAT ON THAT POINT.
BUT LISTEN I APPRECIATE -- WHAT
YOU'RE DOING I'D LIKE TO SEE
THIS MATURE IT'S IT IT'S HARD TO
SUPPORT A BOND -- ELISE FROM MY
NECK OF THE WOODS UNLESS I CAN
DEMONSTRATE TO THE FOLKS I
REPRESENT.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE
OVERLOOKED THIS TIME RIGHT.
AND I WANT AND I DON'T WANT TO
MAKE THAT REPRESENTATION -- THAT
WE'RE GOING -- TO IMPROVE OUR
LOT.
IN THE REGION -- WITHOUT.
THAT ARTICULATION -- IN THE BOND
ITSELF IF IF THAT CAN BE
PROVIDED I I I TOTALLY HEAR YOU
AND I I'D LIKE TO SIT DOWN WITH
YOU AND ALSO OTHER REPS FROM THE
FROM CENTRAL VALLEY TO TALK SHOP
ABOUT HOW WE CAN GET LANGUAGE
THAT GIVES.
YOU KNOW APPROPRIATE LEVELS OF
FLEXIBILITY BUT BUT REALLY DOES
KIND OF DRILL DOWN TO THE KIND
OF CORE.
ISSUES INFRASTRUCTURAL AND AND
INFORMAL JUSTICE ISSUES A YEAR
TRYING TO GET OUT.
AND SO I'D I'D VERY MUCH LIKE TO
WORK WITH WITH BOTH OF YOU AND
OTHERS.
OKAY WE'RE GOING OVER TO CENTER
JONES AND COMMERCENTRE JACKSON.
THEY SURROUND MOST OF MY
CONCERNS OF ALREADY BEEN --
HANDLE IN THE CURRENT TO A
CONVERSATION I I DO WANT TO SAY --
YOU KNOW AT WHAT YOU WANT TO DO.
AS OUTLINED I I THINK I CAN
SUPPORT.
ALMOST ALL OF MOST OF IT -- I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE URGENCY.
A AND DOING A BOND YOU KNOW JUST
KIND OF PUT SOME OF THE STUFF
OFF TILL YOU KNOW AFTER --
TWENTY TWENTY AS THE NEW GUY
HERE AND WITH A TWO YEAR BREAK
BETWEEN TWO HOUSES I'M TRYING TO
GET CAUGHT UP ON THE POLICY AND
BUDGET YOU KNOW PROCESS HERE.
I I THINK.
IF YOU KNOW OF IF WE CAN HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT MOST THESE
ITEMS YOU KNOW THIS CURRENT YEAR --
THROUGH THE POLICY COMMITTEES
AND THE BUDGET COMMITTEE I THINK
WE CAN GET A LOT OF IT DONE THIS
YEAR.
I I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
REGARDING THE BONDING AS HAS
BEEN MENTIONED -- YOU KNOW BOTH
GOVERNOR BROWN AND GOVERNOR'S
SOME HAVE.
AS BEEN SHARED YOUR CONCERN
ABOUT IT UPCOMING.
DOWNTURN IN THE ECONOMY I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
OR NOT -- BUT IF IT DOES THAT
WILL IMPACT THE BONDING
CAPABILITY -- AND AND I REALLY
DO HAVE.
IT THE LAND ACQUISITION PROCESS
IN OVER -- COMPONENTS BY ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I MIGHT YOU KNOW
I MIGHT -- HAVE SOME
DISAGREEMENT ON BUT WE CAN WORK
I THINK WE CAN WE CAN WORK THAT
OUT -- THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO
DO AND I'M AT CURRENTLY TODAY
I'M JUST KINDA UNCOMFORTABLE --
PUTTING THE STATE FURTHER IN
DEBT ARE AUTHORIZING YOU KNOW
FOR THE AT JUST INITIAL DAD BUT
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A LOT OF
THESE CONVERSATIONS.
IN ON THE CURRENT POLICY HEARING
KERR BUDGET YEAR I THINK WE CAN
GET SOME OF IT DONE.
THE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THOSE
COMMENTS CENTER AND I YOU KNOW I
I AS I SAY I CONCERNED ABOUT THE
THE THE FINANCIAL ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED IN AND I MEAN
ULTIMATELY THIS IS.
THE BEGINNING OF A LONG
CONVERSATION THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE AND AND WE AWARE
THIS WILL FIT INTO THE LIST OF
PRIORITIES AND AND I AND I DO
SUPPORT MY COLLEAGUE'S COMMENTS
ON THAT ALL MENTIONED YOU KNOW
THE SCIENCE ASPECT OF IT I I
THINK THAT THAT.
I THINK THAT WOULD SELL TO
CALIFORNIA IN OFFICIALLY GETS
APPROVED ON THE BALLOT I THINK
THAT IS BE IMPORTANT PART OF
THAT CONVERSATION HERE
[inaudible]
YEAH.
SO I DO I I MEAN I COULD BUY IT
SO THE EVERYTHING IT'S BEEN
BROUGHT UP AS ABSOLUTE VALID
THIS THIS HOWEVER WE DO KNOW
THAT THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE ARE
PRICING IN REAL AN URGENT.
AND LONG TERM IN.
IN IN IN MADE.
WITH THE BILL.
HEY WE HAVE A MOTION FROM CENTER
MINING CENTER JACKSON -- I WOULD
BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T ALSO BRING
UP.
THE FACT THAT -- THE BILL HAS A
SECTION FOR CENTRAL VALLEY DAMS
FOR BETTER FLOOD MANAGEMENT
DOESN'T SAY ANYTHING ABOUT ANY
OTHER REGIONS OF THE STATE
INCLUDING THE CENTRAL COAST
WHICH I REPRESENT.
ANDA FREQUENTLY WE FEEL TO THAT
WERE SOMETIMES IGNORED FROM THE
PROCESS -- SO IBM I KNOW THAT MY
STAFF HAS TALKED WITH YOU ABOUT
THE HOPE THAT OBSOLETE DAM
REMOVAL AND RIVER ECOSYSTEM
PROJECTS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
FUNDING.
FRANKLY I HAVE A OF THE MATERIAL
HOW IT'S ACTUALLY THE
INTERNATIONAL SYMBOL OF OBSOLETE
DAM REMOVAL MOVEMENT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO GET THAT REMOVED -- I
THINK IT WAS WHEN SECRETARY
BABBITT WAS THE HEAD OF THE
INTERIOR DEPARTMENT.
OF MANY MANY YEARS AGO -- CAME
UP AND SYMBOLICALLY REMOVED ONE
OF THE CONCRETE.
TO BORDERS AND THAT'S ABOUT ALL
THE TO EVER HAPPEN.
AND SO IT'S MY HOPE THAT -- THAT
THIS WOULD ALSO BE -- CERTAINLY
ELIGIBLE FOR CONSIDERATION IT
ISN'T RIGHT NOW -- IT WILL
RESTORE THE VENTURA RIVER --
IMPROVING OUR RECREATION RIVER
HEALTH FISH STOCKS COASTAL
HEALTH I MEAN THERE WERE A LOT
OF GOOD REASONS THAT THIS MIGHT
BE INCLUDED.
AND IT'S ACTUALLY A VITAL.
OF RESTORATION PROJECT BUT A
TRUSTING AGAIN SEALEVEL RISE SO --
WOULD THIS BE SOMETHING THAT YOU
WOULD BE WILLING TO ADD TO THE
BILL -- AGAIN AS ONE OF THE
OPTIONS I DON'T THINK.
IT'S FAIR TO JUST ASK YOU TO PUT
YOU KNOW TO PUT THIS CHRISTMAS
TREE OUT THERE WITH SPECIFIC --
PROJECTS BUT CERTAINLY WITHIN
THE SUBJECT MATTER OF OBSOLETE
DANCE I WOULD.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT IF YOU
WOULD CONSIDER THAT SO WE COULD
BID FORD AND BEFORE PEOPLE.
THE THE WERE ALIVE WHEN
SECRETARY BABBITT WAS A SECTOR
NO LONGER LIVE SO THEY HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT I'M REFERRING -- TO
IT'S SORT OF LIKE YOUNG PEOPLE
TODAY DON'T KNOW JUDY COLLINS IS
I MEAN IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S IT
SAID GENERATION.
AND YES SEAT NOT ARGUING ALL FOR
DON'T YOU CAN YOU CAN'T KID MAKE
BUT IT WOULD BE HELPFUL IF WE
COULD ALSO CONSIDER THOSE
ASPECTS AS PART OF IT IS WHAT.
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT MY
ASSESSMENT HAS FOR YEARS AND
THAT THAT THAT'S THE PLAN. TO
PROTECT CONVERSION OPTION.
YEAH VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION I DON'T WANT TO
BELABOR THIS BUT I APPRECIATE.
THEM.
YOUR DEXTERITY AND SORT OF
OPENNESS TO THINKING ABOUT HOW
TO MAKE THIS.
THIS KIND OF BOND PERFORM.
BUT I DO WANT TO RESET THE
CONVERSATION TO THAT.
THE RISK IS STILL GOING TO BE
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
THIS IS NOT EVEN GOING TO BE A
DROP IN THE BUCKET COMPARED TO
THE SCOPE OF THE RISKS OF THIS
STATE RIGHT EVEN OVER THE LIFE
OF THIS BOX.
THERE A LOT OF OTHER WAYS TO PAY
FOR THIS STUFF TOO WE'RE GONNA
NEED ALL THOSE WAYS.
THE RATE PAYERS ARE GONNA BEAR
SOME OF THE RISK ON WILDFIRE.
HOW MUCH CAN THEY BEAR?
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE GOING TO
BEAR THE COSTS OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND YOU KNOW DEALING
WITH FLOODED HOMES AND TRYING TO
YOU KNOW DREDGE UP UNDER BRIDGE
THAT YOU CAN GET.
SEVEN FLOOD YOU KNOW WATER
MOVING THROUGH THERE IN A IN A
IN A CRISIS AVOIDING LIABILITIES
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF LIABILITIES THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
THE FARMING COMMUNITY I MEAN IT
THE LIST GOES ON I THINK.
MAIN MY GOAL WOULD BE THAT.
WE CONTINUE NOT JUST TO TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE MEMBERS THIS
COMMITTEE -- BUT TO REALLY PUT
AN ANALYTICAL FRAMEWORK TOGETHER
THAT'S GOING TO GIVE THAT SENSE
OF PERFORMANCE HERE THAT I THINK.
WE CAN PROBABLY FIND.
A MULTI REGIONAL BI PARTISAN
ANSWER HERE THAT WE DON'T WANT
TO OVER INFLATE WHAT THIS IS
GONNA SOLVE EITHER BECAUSE AGAIN
I DON'T KNOW IF WE CAN AFFORD TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM RIGHT NOW BUT
A BOND.
IS IT IS AN ISSUANCE OF TRUST
AND IT'S SAYING THAT WE RIGHT
NOW IN PRESENT DAY CAN'T AFFORD
THE SCOPE OF THIS RACE BUT WE'RE
GONNA MAKE A PROMISE TO THE
FUTURE.
THE PEOPLE LIVING CALIFORNIA SAY
LIKE WE ALL COLLECTIVELY HAVE TO
SOLVE THIS AND EVEN YOU KNOW
YOUR SON -- WHO INDIA OF TWENTY
YEARS THIRTY YEARS?
I THINK SPEAKING ON HIS BEHALF
IS FAIR IN THIS CASE BECAUSE
EVEN THOUGH.
THOSE THOSE PEOPLE TO LIVE HERE
CAN'T CAN'T SPEAK UP RIGHT NOW --
THAT VOICE HAS TO COME THROUGH
TO SO YEAH EVERYTHING JUST
BURNED OUT.
MY COMMUNITY MY HOME EVERYTHING
WE KNOW THAT IT'S HAPPENING
EVERYWHERE AND IT'S NOT JUST
FIRE IT'S PEOPLE'S LIVELIHOODS
THE ENTIRE CULTURE THIS STATE.
SO IT'S BIG -- BUT I I
APPRECIATE THE THE DILIGENCE AND
THE INSIDE FROM THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE HERE TO REALLY TRY
TO HONE A PRODUCT HERE THAT.
WE REALLY CAN BRING TO THE
VOTERS THE CALIFORNIA SO I WOULD
JUST ASK FIRST I WANTED I WANTED
JOINT ON AND I WANT TO BE A
PARTNER WITH YOU ON THIS EFFORT
BUT ALSO AS THIS MOVES FORWARD.
I JUST WORK OF THE COMMITTEE BUT
BRING THIS BACK TO COMMITTEE AND
LET US SORT OF SEE WHAT THE
SECOND ROUND OF THIS PRODUCT CAN
LOOK LIKE IN.
LET'S LOOK FOR THAT COLLECTIVE
SORT OF YEAH EQUITY STAKE IF YOU
WILL.
YOU OPEN TO THAT OKAY GREAT --
CONTINUED CONVERSATION THE START
THANK YOU FOR THE INPUT TODAY I
I THINK THERE'S SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT HERE -- SO WE DO HAVE
A MOTION FOR SENATOR MINING AND
AND THE WAY IT'S GONNA WORK WE
CAN'T AMEND TODAY GIVEN THE
TIMING BECAUSE YOU'RE ARE YOU
TROUBLE REFERRED. TO YOUR TRIP
FOR FOR SO FIRST OF MANY -- BUT
WITH THE AT THE AMENDMENTS THAT
YOU ACCEPT I THINK WILL BE
ADOPTED AN ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
SO THE MOTION IS JUST TO PASS TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY -- SO WITH
THAT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
SORRY YES [inaudible]
YES PLEASE.
FORGIVE ME I DON'T KNOW SO.
WITH THIS ITEM BE BROUGHT BACK --
AS YOU JUST MENTIONED BEFORE OF
WAR ONCE IS REFERRED WE HAVE TO
WAIT TO THE VERY END.
TIMING WISE I THINK WE WOULD
HAVE TO WAIT -- WELL TO TO THE
END OF THE PROCESS FOR ANOTHER
REFERRAL BUT I THINK THE POINT
IS THAT WE DO WE COMMIT TO A A
SUBSTANTIVE HEARING NOT JUST A A
A A SORT OF WE WOULD WE WOULD
TAKE THE REFERRAL FROM RULES AND
HEAR THIS AGAIN.
BUT WHETHER THAT OCCURS BEFORE A
FLOOR VOTE -- OR AFTER THE OTHER
HOUSE -- I DON'T KNOW.
AFTER THE OTHER HOUSE SO WOULD
IT WOULD BE IF IF THIS WERE TO
MOVE THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY WE
WOULD SEE THIS BACK.
OKAY SO I THINK THAT'S THE TIME
IS THIS IS THE POLICY HEARING IN
THIS HOUSE BUT WE WOULD CALL IT
BACK FOR A POLICY HEARING IF IT
MADE IT OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY.
HOWEVER I DON'T I ALSO THINK
BEFORE APPROPRIATIONS THE FLOOR
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY GOING TO BE
CONTINUED SUBSTANCE CONVERSATION
SO I'D SAY YOU KNOW WE PUT SOME
KIND OF GROUP TOGETHER AND START.
REALLY WORKING ON THIS BUT I
THINK THAT'S THE FORMAL PROCESS.
THAT IS THAT HELPFUL.
AND I THINK RATING AT THE END OF
TRYING TO I'M TRYING TO MAKE
SURE I UNDERSTAND.
SO WITH THE FRIENDLY AMENDMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN PUT FORWARD AND
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED HERE.
THEY WOULD BE INCORPORATED OR
YOUR PROPOSAL BE MODIFIED.
OR STAY IN ITS CURRENT FORM
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT TO SET OF
COMMITTEES INTO ANOTHER HOUSE.
I THINK JUST PROCEDURALLY --
WE'VE ACCEPTED THE COMMITMENTS
FOR YOU Q. THE ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS WE TALKED ABOUT TODAY.
I WOULD WE EITHER GET IT IN
PLACE BEFORE EACH YEAR WITH
PEOPLE THE THIRD REFERRAL DO YOU
KNOW.
I THINK THAT THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS WILL GO IN AND
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY THE
CONCEPTUAL COMMITMENTS WILL
OBVIOUSLY BE THERE UNTIL -- I
WOULD IMAGINE APPROPRIATIONS
IT'S PROBABLY THE THAT BE THAT
IT'S A PRETTY COMPRESS PUREED
YOU'VE GOT HERE SO I THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY THE NEXT.
VENUE OR THE POOR BEFORE THE
FLOOR.
WHAT MAYBE BEFORE GOVERNMENT'S
FINANCIER?
ABSOLUTELY YEAH ABSOLUTELY.
pIMAGINING THERE'S GONNA BE A V.
ONE V. TWO V. THREE THIS IS
GOING TO KEEP EVOLVING HERE BUT
BUT IF.
YEAH ASSUMING IT PASSES YEAH.
BUT I MEAN IF PUTTING I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING -- ON ON A
CORPORATE IN THIS DISCUSSION
INTO THE BILL AND AND EVEN IF
THERE'S NOT A FORMAL HEARING OF
THIS COMMITTEE.
TOMORROW THAT DOESN'T STOP ANY
OF US FROM WORKING TOGETHER
TALKING TO EACH OTHER ABOUT
[inaudible]
ABOUT.
CONGRESS HAS IN WHAT WE TALKED
ABOUT INTO THE BOND THE LANGUAGE
OF THE BOND -- BEFORE IT GETS
OUT OF THE SENATE.
SO MISTER CHAIR I I THINK JUST
FOR PURPOSES OF MY STING
OLLEAGUE HE'S TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE HIS VOTE.
GOES AND HOW IT GETS RECORDED
AND SO -- I'M PREPARED TO
SUPPORT IT -- I'M ASSUMING IT'S
GONNA GET BETTER GIVEN THE
COMMENTS THAT WE MADE AND SO --
THAT THAT IT'S WHY I'M A YES
VOTE -- BUT I THINK THAT WAS
PART OF THE REASON FOR THE FOR
THE QUESTION AND YOU WILL GET
ALSO A SECOND BITE AT THIS APPLE --
YOU COULD YOU DON'T SIT IN
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE THREE YOU
KNOW BUT BEFORE THE BUT BEFORE
THE FLOOR I MEAN.
WHAT I'M HEARING FROM YOU TODAY
IS?
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A NEW PRODUCT --
COMING FOR THE AT LEAST COMING
BACK TO THE MEMBERS IS
COMMITTEES TO REVIEW AND SEE IF
WE'VE SORT OF MEMORIALIZE
SOMEBODY'S CONCERNS AND WORK
THROUGH IT.
PRIOR TO A SECOND VOTE NOT A
BRAND NEW PRODUCT AN IMPROVED
PRODUCT NEW AND IMPROVED.
IMPROVED I'LL LEAVE MY COME OF
THIS I WILL I'M GOING TO STAY IN
ON TODAY'S VOTE.
BUT I APPLAUD YOU FOR WHAT
YOU'RE DOING I WOULD LIKE TO
WORK WITH YOU IN ITS FINAL
PRODUCT IF IT'S WITH THE
PROTECTIONS THAT WE TALKED ABOUT.
I'D BE VERY INTERESTED IN NOT
BEING SUPPORTED IN REVIEWING
THAT THAT TIME THANK YOU FOR THE
SENATE VERY GOOD -- THAT FURTHER
DO -- THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
VERY MINUTE QUALITY PLEASE CALL
CENTERS STERN.
TURN I'D JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BURGESS.
CABALLERO CABALLERO AYE
HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE
MONEY IN MONEY AND I IT HAS SIX
SCREWS OKAY ON THAT IS SIX VOTES
WILL PUT THAT ON CALL OKAY
MOVING RIGHT ALONG [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- BOY WONDER HIMSELF
FROM THE NORTH COAST.
COMING DOWN THE PIKE SB TWO
SIXTY TWO GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME SENATOR MCGUIRE.
IN THE HOT SEAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALLOWING US TO BE HERE I
KNOW THAT ALL OF YOU HAVE A
ROBUST.
DISCUSSION AND WOULD LIKE TO
BETTER TALK ABOUT ALL ISSUES OF
FISH -- THE GREAT CITY
CALIFORNIA PROVIDES AMERICA WITH
FRESH HEALTHY -- IN WILD CAUGHT
SEAFOOD THE GOLDEN STATE'S
COMMERCIAL FISHING FLEET IS
WORTH ABOUT SEVEN BILLION
ANNUALLY IN A RECREATIONAL
FISHING INDUSTRIES WORTH ANOTHER
TWO BILLION.
CALIFORNIA'S AMONG THE TOP
SEAFOOD PRODUCING STATES IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND THE
JOINT COMMITTEES ON FISHERIES
AND AQUACULTURE WORKS WITH THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF HARD
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN OF THE
GOLDEN STATE'S COMMERCIAL
RECREATIONAL FISHING FLEETS.
IN ADVANCES IN ON THIS BILL
EVERY FEW YEARS TO REMEDY ISSUES
AND CHALLENGES LARGE AND SMALL
HERE IS WHAT SB TWO SIXTY TWO
WOULD DO.
NUMBER ONE AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
IN INDEXES COMMERCIAL LANDING
FEES.
OFF OF THE STANDARD PROGRAM FROM
THE US DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE
WHICH IS ALREADY IN PLACE FOR
GOODS AND SERVICES SO WE AVOID
WHAT WE SAW TWO YEARS AGO OF A
13100% INCREASE.
PROPOSED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE BECAUSE FEES
WERE NEVER RAISED OVER ALMOST
TWO DECADES THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
EXTEND THE SUNSET DATE.
OF THE CHAIRS FAVORITE
AQUACULTURE -- SPECIE THE SEA
CUCUMBER -- IT EXTENDS A SUNSET
DATE OF THE SEA CUCUMBER PERMIT
PROGRAM IN THE CURRENT SENSE
THAT DATE IS APRIL FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY HI THIS BILL
COMPILED ISSUES THAT AFFECT
FISHING RESOURCES PROTECTION
INTO A SINGLE.
PIECE OF LEGISLATION NUMBER THE
GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE HERE TODAY
NO OPPENHEIM.
HE'S EXECUTIVE RECORD THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATIONS WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU MISTER OPPENHEIM
FOR ALL OF HIS WORK ESPECIALLY
ON ALL ISSUES OF CRAP IT IS BEEN
A CHALLENGING TIME.
IN GERMAN TO MY LEFT FROM ROSS'S
EXACTLY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FISHERIES AND SEAFOOD
INSTITUTE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
SENATE MCGUIRE WELCOME GENTLEMAN.
THANK YOU WAS CHAIRED IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE WITH YOU
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF.
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY TWO IS AN
INCREDIBLE WE IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY -- TO HEAD OFF ONE
OF THE MORE INTENSE CHALLENGES
THAT I HAVE TO DO DEAL WITH MY
PROFESSIONAL CAREER.
WHICH IS THE THE PUNCTUATED
EQUILIBRIUM OF 13100%.
TAX INCREASES WHICH WERE
PROPOSED TWO YEARS AGO FOR THE
COMMERCIAL FISHING INDUSTRY --
THE PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATIONS IS
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
APPROACH INDEXING LANDINGS FEE
INCREASES. TO SOMETHING LIKE THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX -- AS
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL.
IN ADDITION THE SEA CUCUMBER
FISHERY RE AUTHORIZATION IS IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP TO TAKE TO RE
AUTHORIZE THIS IMPORTANT
PORTFOLIO SPECIES TO ALLOW THIS
AND WILL HARVEST OF OF A OF A
SMALL FISHERY.
THAT WILL ALLOW SMALL BOAT AND
AND MEDIUM SCALE FISHERMEN TO
CONTINUE TO PERSIST AND SURVIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK RESTAURANTS MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ROB ROSS OFA HALF THE
CALIFORNIA FISHERIES AND SEAFOOD
INSTITUTE. TWO YEARS AGO YOU
HEARD ABOUT THE PROPOSED 13100%
INCREASE TURNS OUT THAT SINCE
THEY LAST RAISE TAXES. TO THAT
POINT.
WE LOOKED AT THE CPI AND IT WAS
JUST LESS THAN A 100%.
WE DIDN'T DO THEN WHAT WE'RE
DOING NOW AND THAT IS INDEXING
THOSE.
FEES AND TAXES -- JUST LIKE
EVERY SINGLE OTHER -- FIGURE
TAXES IMPOSED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND GAME ALL OF THE MATH
AS WELL WE WANT COLA.
TO I'M A CO YEAR COLETTE ASTRI
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER US OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
THE MOTION FROM SENATOR MINING.
ANY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE MEMBERS COMMENTS
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THE WARTY SEA CUCUMBER.
YES THE ARTICULAR DAHLE I I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE MOST
POPULAR -- INDEED -- CENTER
CABALLERO -- WIND SHE TALKS BUT
HE COME AND CUCUMBERS SHE
PREFERS THAT CORRECT CENTER
COPIER.
ABSOLUTELY IT'S IT'S MY FAVORITE
AS WELL.
SHOULD WE TREAT THAT AS HIS
CLOTHES NO I'M SO I MEAN IS IT
POSSIBLE GET LIKE HALF DEAL.
KOSHER THEY ACTUALLY COME.
SO THEY COME DRIED -- SO WHAT
ENDS UP HAPPENING IS THEY THEY
CAPTURE -- IN THESE SHE COULD
CONVERSE IN AND THEY DRIVE OUT
IN MOST OF THEM ARE SENT
OVERSEAS -- IN OUR A DELICACY BY
WHEN YOU ADD WATER TO THEM --
WELL WITH THAT ROBUST DISCUSSION.
CLOSE.
WITH RESPECT LASSEN AYE BORN
AGAIN MISTER THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR WORK ON THANK YOU -- THE
MOTION IS FROM SENATOR MINING IT
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL I JUST MAKE
A COMMENT I'M SO SORRY HOLD THE
ROLE DIALOGUE HOLD THE ROLE I
DID NOT MEAN TO MOVE WITHOUT YOU
KNOW THAT'S OKAY I WANTED THREE
CURVEBALL -- I COULD BUT NO
TODAY I DON'T LIKE INDEXED --
FEES I THINK THAT THE WHEN THE
FEES COME IN.
THAT'S PROVIDES SUNLIGHT AND A
AND A SON AND A ACTUAL SUNSET ON
THE IDEAS SITE I PRE.
I PREFER FOR FEES TO BE DEBATED
AND TALKED ABOUT WHEN THEY COME
UP FOR RENEWAL SO.
I THANK YOU.
ALL I WOULD SAY IS RICH WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS WHAT HAPPENED
LAST TIME THERE WAS NO ABILITY
TO BE ABLE TO INCREASE FEES --
IN THAT ENDED UP.
WITH A PROPOSED 13100% INCREASE --
AND I ENDED UP WITH A 100%
INCREASE WHICH IS ALSO
ASTRONOMICAL FOR FLEET IS
ALREADY STRUGGLING BUT RESPECT
THAT.
GOOD -- MOTION TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS WHOSE CULTURAL
CENTERS STERN AYE STERN AYE
JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN.
ALLEN HI BARGES.
GORGEOUS I CABALLERO CABALLERO
AYE HERTZBERG.
HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON.
MONNING MONEY.
NINE THE BILL HAS SUFFICIENT
VOTE LOCATED HILLS LOCATION WAS
BELIEVE IT ON CALL -- THANK YOU
SO MUCH SENATE REQUIRE.
MOVING RIGHT ALONG CENTER HUESO
SORRY I CENTER CHIANG.
CENTER HUESO WOULD YOU MIND
YIELDING TO SENATOR CHIANG.
CHRIS.
SINCE BECAUSE HE'S A MEMBER
WOULD YOU MIND I'M SO SORRY.
THAT ALL RIGHT.
THERE CHIANG.
LET ME TO JUMP START YOU THERE
SIR HUESO -- SB FOUR OH FOUR
THAT'S THE ONLY ONE WE HAVE
BEFORE US TODAY.
THE CORRECT.
OKAY.
IT'S VERY GOOD WELCOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SURE STERN AND MEMBERS I JUST
WANNA PRESS OFFICE VIA THE A
CONVERSATION IT -- I WILL BE
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDED BY THE COMMITTEE.
AND WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS AS
BEFORE -- FOR WILL REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
FOR THE ACQUISITION.
OF FOUR PARCELS TO EXPAND CHINO
HILLS STATE PARK.
DOING SO WILL CONTINUE TO
PRESERVE OPEN SPACE FOR
GENERATIONS OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIANS ARE ABLE TO
EXPERIENCE RESPITE IN THE AREA
THAT ONLY.
CHINO HILLS STATE PARK PROVIDES
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR WHEN
THE STATE PARK AND RECREATION
COMMISSION OFFICIALLY DECLARE
THE ORIGINAL.
TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN ACRES OF LAND A
UNIT OF THE STATE PARKS SYSTEM.
CHINO HILLS STATE PARK BECAME A
LANDMARK THAT SITS AT THE
JUNCTION OF FOUR OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST POPULOUS COUNTIES ORANGES
SAN MARINO LOS ANGELES AND
RIVERSIDE. TO THE EFFORT TO
PRESERVE OPEN SPACE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIANS ARE NOW ABLE TO
EXPLORE AND COME AWAY FROM CHINO
STATE PARK FEELING REFRESHED
AFTER YOU LIGHTING IT'S MANY
TRAILS AND CAMPGROUNDS. FOR
STUDENTS OF ALL AGES YOU KNOW
STATE PARK ALSO SERVES AS AN
IDEAL LOCATION TO LEARN.
MILLION VISITORS ARE ABLE TO
OBSERVE MANY WILDLIFE SPECIES
NATIVE TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
DUE TO THE PARKS DIVERSE
HABITATS AND MICRO CLIMATES.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION THE LOCAL DIVERSITY
OF NATIVE PLANTS AND ANIMALS
LOCATED IN THIS AREA.
IS GREATER THAN ANY OTHER AREA
OF COMPARABLE SIZE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
ADDITIONALLY CHEN HOST THE PARK
PROVIDES OPPORTUNITIES TO
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES TO
ACHIEVE A HEALTHIER LIFESTYLE DO
THE ACCESS TO THE PARKS MANY
TRAILS THAT ARE USED FOR MANY
HEALTHY ACTIVITIES. FOR THESE
AND OTHER REASONS IT IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
ENSURE ACCESS TO OPEN SPACE FOR
FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIANS.
CHINO HILLS STATE PARK IS THE
RESULT OF THIRTY FOUR
ACQUISITIONS OVER THIRTY SIX
YEARS BUT IT IS STILL INCOMPLETE.
THE FOUR PARCELS THAT AS BEFORE --
FOR PROPOSES TO ACQUIRE WILL
CONTINUE THE VISION THAT WAS SET
BY THE STATE PARKS DEPARTMENT IN
THEIR NINETEEN NINETY NINE
GENERAL PLAN FOR CHINO HILLS.
A PART.
OF THOSE A PARKS DEPARTMENT HAS
BEEN ABLE TO ACQUIRE LAND IN THE
PAST TO GROW THE SIZE --
PRESERVE OPEN SPACE IN THIS
COMMUNITY THIS PROCESS OF
ACQUIRING LAND HAS NOT BEEN
CARRIED OUT IN YEARS.
AS A COMEDIAN ALSO STATES WE
BELIEVE THAT AS BEFORE FOR THE
WAKE UP CALL TO THE DEPARTMENT
TO BEGIN STRATEGIC PROPERTY
ACQUISITIONS AGAIN.
HERE WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUED THE TRADITION OF
PRESERVING THE WILDLIFE CORRIDOR
IN THE COMMUNITY.
AN OPPORTUNITY THAT HASN'T
PRESENTED ITSELF FOR MANY YEARS
I WILL LET MY WITNESS CLEAR SHOT
A BACK SPEAK MORE ON THE DETAILS
OF EACH PARCEL BUT THREE OF THE
PROPOSED PROPERTIES THAT AMOUNT
TO APPROXIMATELY ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN ACRES.
OF LAND OWNERS THAT ARE WILLING
SELLERS THE STATE PARKS
DEPARTMENT.
AND ELEVEN ACRE PROPERTY KNOWN
AS THE PT PROPERTY IS POVERTY
THAT THE LANDOWNER HAS BEEN
WILLING TO DONATE TO THE STATE
PARKS DEPARTMENT.
AND I ALSO WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
AS INDICATED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THAT THE BILL IS NOT
SEEKING APPROPRIATIONS SINCE THE
LAND THAT IS AVAILABLE FOR
ACQUISITION CAN BE ATTAINED.
WITH FUNDS FROM OTHER SOURCES OR
IN ONE CASE DONATE OUT RIGHT WE
BELIEVE THAT DIRECTION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO ACQUIRE AMENITIES
PARCEL.
IS REQUIRED AND THAT IS WHY SB
FULL FORCE ABSOLUTELY NEEDED
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE
TO TURN OVER TO MY WITNESS CLEAR
SLAUGHTER BACK EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF HILLS FOR EVERYONE
THE BILL SPONSORED.
HUMANS TURNING MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE ARE GROUP FOUNDED%
THIS STATE PARK FOR THIS WORK
THE STATE PARKS DEPARTMENT GAVE
US ITS HIGHEST HONOR THE TO WAIT
AWARD IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN THE PARK
HAS BEEN THE MOST COMPLICATED
SET OF ACQUISITIONS IN STATE
PARK HISTORY SITTING AS IT DOES
AT THE JUNCTURE OF LOS ANGELES
ORANGE.
SAN BERNARDINO AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTIES IN THE MIDST OF
EIGHTEEN MILLION PEOPLE.
CHINO HILLS IS ALSO ONE OF THE
NEWEST STATE PARKS AND IS NOT
YET FINISHED.
IT WAS DESIGNED A LONG RIDGE
LANE BOUNDARIES SO THAT ONCE
YOU'RE INSIDE THE PARK YOU DON'T
KNOW THAT ALL THOSE OTHER PEOPLE
ARE ON THE OUTSIDE OF IT.
IT WAS DESIGNED TO PROTECT THE
WATERSHED FOR WILDLIFE AND IF
YOU SHED FOR VISITORS IN PARKS
START TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AFTER LITERALLY FORTY YEARS OF
TRYING -- TO ACQUIRE THESE LANDS
WE FINALLY HAVE WILLING SELLERS
OF THE UNPROTECTED EASTERN RIDGE
WIND.
AMONG OTHER SOURCES WE ARE
LINING UP FUNDING FROM SECTION
SIX WHILE THE W. C. B. AND LAND
AND WATER CONSERVATION FUNDS.
ALL WE NEED IS STATE PARKS TO
TAKE TITLE TO THE LAND IT HAS
ALWAYS WANTED.
WE ARE NOT ALONE IN WANTING DPR
TO ONCE AGAIN.
ADD PARSLEY AND THE RIVERS AND
LANDS CONSERVANCY OWNS LAND THE
D. P. R. PROMISED TO TURN INTO
SANTA MATTEO CANYON STATE PARK
OVER TWELVE YEARS AGO.
IN TO BREAK GO FOUNDATION OWNS
IN HOLDINGS DP ARE ONCE.
IN TWO THOUSAND DPR BOUGHT LAND
TO CONNECT OUR HILLS TO THE
SANTA ANA MOUNTAINS WITH A
WILDLIFE CROSSING UNDER THE
NINETY ONE FREEWAY.
THIS WAS THE FIRST TIME LAND WAS
BOUGHT FOR THE CONNECTIVE ITTY
BY STATE PARKS.
THE LA TIMES JUST REPORTED WE
MAY LOSE COUGARS INTO SEVEN
CALIFORNIA MOUNTAIN RANGES
UNLESS WE WINK MORE LANDS.
THAT NEED FOR WILDLIFE CORRIDORS
IS ON GOING AND YET STRATEGIC
ACQUISITIONS ARE NOT I'M GOING.
WE NEED DEEP YARD TO LIFT ITS
COLLECTIVE HEAD FROM
ORGANIZATIONAL ISSUES CONSUMING
IT.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS UNDERGONE A
DECADE LONG PROCESS OF REFORM
REFORM SAID AT THIS POINT POINT
FEEL MORE LIKE PENDANTS AND
STARVATION. FOR THE SINS FROM
LONG AGO.
PLEASE HELP THE DEPARTMENT
BECOME THE GREAT PARTNERS FOR
SUSTAINABLE LANDSCAPES THEY ONCE
WERE.
BY ALLOWING THESE ACQUISITIONS
TO MOVE FORWARD I URGE A YES
VOTE ON THE AMENDED SB.
FOUR OH FOUR THANK YOU THANKS SO
MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE THE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE MEMBERS QUESTIONS
COMMENTS [inaudible]
MOTION.
MOTION FOR CENTER HUESO -- AND
TO CARE FOR YOU YOUR THANK YOU
FOR WORK ON THE AMENDMENTS
YOU'RE ACCEPTING THOSE TODAY
OKAY -- WHAT'S THE HOPE THAT
THIS SORT OF NECESSITY DRIVEN
ASSISTANCE -- KNOWLEDGE -- IN
THOUGH IN THE AMENDMENT LANGUAGE --
FOR YIELD SOME POSITIVE OUTCOME
FOR THE COMMUNITY SAID THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
THE THE MOTION IS -- DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS SO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CENTER
STERN.
AYE STERN AYE JONES.
JONES I ALLEN ALLEN AYE BURGESS
BURGESS AYE AYE CABALLERO.
CAREER AYE HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY AYE THE HAS SUFFICIENT
DECISION WAS WE WILL LEAVE IT ON
CALL THANKS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GET NOW.
NOW STEP RIGHT UP THE CENTER
FROM [inaudible]
SAN DIEGO.
SB.
THREE SIXTY SEVEN APOLOGIZE FOR
THE FOSTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS.
ARTS MINOR TO PRESENT SB THREE
THIRTY SIX SEVEN THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY -- THIS IS A
BILL THAT -- WILLING.
THE STATE BECAUSE THE
CONSERVANCY'S AUTHORITY TO
PROVIDE GRANTS -- FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THE PROTECTING OUR
STATE'S CULTURE RESOURCES BUT
ALSO.
AT HELPING TO IMPROVE -- BUT THE
PUBLIC'S ACCESS TO THE COAST
LINE ACROSS THE STATE.
SINCE THE CREATION OF THE
COASTAL ACT.
THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY WAS
CREATED FOR THE PURPOSE OF
HELPING -- TO IMPROVE THE
COASTLINE HELP TO ESTABLISH A TO
ACQUIRE LANDS TO HELP.
THE PUBLIC IT GREATER ACCESS TO
TO THE COASTLINE -- THERE BEEN
OZ VARIOUS RESTORATION PROJECTS
MITIGATION PROJECTS --
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
PROJECTS.
BUT YOU KNOW.
THE THE THE COAST CONSERVANCY'S
BEEN DOING PHENOMENAL WORK
ACROSS THE STATE MANY PEOPLE
WILL AGREE.
THAT OF THE COASTLINE IS VERY
IMPORTANT -- TO TO THE STATE TO
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE IT'S
IT'S IMPORTANT -- FOR RECREATION
IT'S IMPORTANT.
FOR THERE IS SOME IT'S ALSO IN A
ESSENTIAL TO OUR ECONOMY.
SO -- DOING MORE FOR FOR THE
COAST IS ALWAYS IMPORTANT.
THIS BILL WOULD IT WOULD ADD AN
EDUCATIONAL ELEMENT TO THE GRANT
MAKING PROCESS BECAUSE OF COURSE --
STEWARDSHIP OF OF THE COASTLINE
INVOLVES THE PUB PUBLIC IT
INVOLVES EVERYONE.
A WE WE NEED EVERYBODY'S HELP TO
BE A IT ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
HELPING TO PRESERVE PROTECT.
AND AND I CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THAT ACCESS TO THE COASTLINE AND
AND DECIDE TO EDUCATIONAL
ELEMENT TO THE CONSERVANCY WHERE.
GRANTS CAN BE MADE TO
ORGANIZATIONS THAT.
OF PROVIDE AN EDUCATIONAL
SUPPORT -- THIS OF WOULD EXTEND.
TO EDUCATIONAL ORG --
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
EDUCATION TO THE PUBLIC.
IT ALSO PROVIDES SUPPORT TRIBES
NONPROFITS AND PUBLIC AGENCIES.
WHO WORK TO EDUCATE THE PUBLIC --
ABOUT -- COASTAL ACCESS AND
COASTAL PROTECTION.
I SB THREE SIX SEVEN WILL BUILD
ON THE CONSERVANCY'S EFFORT TO
INCREASE COASTAL ACCESS.
AND AND IT'LL ALSO -- BY.
NOT ONLY ALLOWING THESE GRANTS
ARE ALSO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO PEOPLE THAT ARE --
ELECTED -- TO APPLY SO IT'S A A
VERY THOUGHTFUL BILL THAT WILL
HELP MORE PEOPLE APPLY.
BUT ALSO -- HELP PEOPLE APPLY
THERE ARE ARE PROVIDING THAT
EDUCATIONAL MEANT TO COASTAL
ACCESS TO PROTECTION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER HUESO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BOB
REAP WITH READ GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
DIEGO MARITIME MUSEUM IN SUPPORT --
BE PLEASED TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
BURGER WHICH A MAP OF HEAL THE
BAY IN SUPPORT.
THANKS GOOD MORNING JAMIE GO ON
BEHALF OF A SOUL AS WELL AS
AUTUMN ON CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LAUREN COMMON BE HAVE THE SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL.
I SEE NO THERE'S IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION.
NONE -- WILL BRING IT BACK --
JUST TO CLARIFY ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS YES GREAT.
THANK YOU FOR THE HARD WORK. FOR
ME STAFF AND WITH THE COMMITTEE --
MEMBERS QUESTIONS COMMENTS I
JUST I AM A FAN OF THE AUTHOR
FAN OF THE SPONSOR GREAT MUSEUM
IN SAN DIEGO AND THAT THE CAUSE
AND I SECOND -- CENTERS MOTION
[inaudible]
GOOD.
I WE DO HAVE A MOTION --
QUESTIONS COME OKAY CENTER JONES.
A QUICK CONCERNED ANSWER HUESO
ON THE IT SOUNDS GREAT -- I
SUPPORT A LOT OF THE IDEAS THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE.
IT'S KIND OF BROAD -- TO ME IN
AND ONE OF THE THINGS I'M
CONCERNED AS ELIMINATES ANY
OVERSIGHT BY THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION ON THESE GRANTS -- BUT
MORE CONCERNING TO ME ARE THE
PROGRAMS EDUCATION PROGRAMS ARE
GOING TO BE DEVELOPED -- CAN YOU
TALK TO YOU KNOW WHAT KIND
OVERSIGHT.
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE ON
THAT OR OF STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION.
WELL OF COURSE THE OVERSIGHT IS
PROVIDED BY THE CLOSE CLOSE --
CULTURE CONSERVANCY WHICH HAS
BOARD BUT THE BILL.
SPECIFICALLY MENTIONS THERE'S A
REFERENCE -- TO THOSE EDUCATION --
ORG DOES EDUCATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE TO PROVIDE --
EDUCATION - THAT'S CONSISTENT
WHAT WHAT THE STATE'S
EDUCATIONAL POLICIES.
AND WITHIN.
BUT THE THE STATE'S EDUCATIONAL
GOALS SO THERE IS A COORDINATION
WITH THE SUPERINTENDENT'S OFFICE
WITH THIS BILL.
AND THERE IS THERE IS OVERSIGHT --
IT FROM ALL THOSE VARIOUS STATE
AGENCIES THAT DEAL WITH
EDUCATION.
WHAT DOES IT GO FROM HERE?
YEAH A BROKEN [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
CAN CAN WE HAVE SOME FOLLOW UP
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS BEFORE
BECAUSE OF HER.
VERY GOOD WELL THANK YOU AND I
JUST.
OUT I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY AND APPRECIATE THE
HARDWARE FOR THE STAFF AND AND
THIS IS THIS EFFORT.
TO BOTH -- IMPROVE THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE EXISTING
PROGRAM WE KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT FUNDING SOURCES THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO PUSH THROUGH THE
CONSERVANCY WE THINK THEY'VE
BEEN DOING A GREAT JOB.
EXPANDED MISSION EDUCATION BUT
STILL STAYING CONSISTENT WITH
THAT BROAD MISSION OF EDUCATING
ABOUT.
ENVIRONMENTAL BUT ALSO INCLUDING
LEADERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES AND
OTHER SORT OF WAYS TO ENHANCE
THAT EDUCATION I LIKE THIS SORT
OF ACTION COMPONENT TO IT ALL --
AND ALLOWING ADULTS ACCESS I
THINK IS ANOTHER REALLY
IMPORTANT POINT HERE THAT.
YOUTH MATTER -- BUT IF WE CAN
ENGAGE A WHOLE FAMILY IN
UNDERSTANDING GET WHAT ACCESS
REALLY CAN MEAN TO THEM I THINK
IT CHANGED PEOPLE'S LIVES SO.
GRAND AMBITION FOR PRETTY SIMPLE
BUILD BUT THANK YOU FOR BRING IT
FORWARD WE DO HAVE A MOTION --
WITH THAT -- WOULD LIKE YOU TO
CLOSE.
THIS GENERALLY CALIFORNIA'S
COASTLINE BELONGS TO EVERYBODY
CALIFORNIA NOT JUST PEOPLE THAT
LIVE ON THE COAST.
WHERE THAT RESIDE ON A COASTAL
CITY?
IT BELONGS TO THE PEOPLE THAT
LIVE IN THE VALLEY IN THE DESERT
SUN AND MOUNTAINS.
AND SOMETIMES -- THAT ACCESS IS
VERY DIFFICULT.
AND ALLOWING -- THE CONSERVANCY
TO DRAW FURTHER DEEPER AND
DEEPER INTO THE STATE TO GET
PEOPLE TO APPRECIATE THEIR CLOSE
AND ALSO HAVE.
NOT ONLY A POSITIVE EXPERIENCE
BUT A LEARNING EXPERIENCE AND
AND AND I THINK EVERYBODY IN THE
STATE TO LEARN THAT THEY HAVE.
A RESPONSIBILITY TO TO CARE FOR
THE COAST -- IT WHEN THEY VISIT
AND WHEN THEY RECREATION SO --
THIS IS -- OF A BILL THAT'S
GOING TO ADD A VERY IMPORTANT
ELEMENT TO COASTAL PROTECTION
THROUGH EDUCATION.
AS FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU -- MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR STERN STERN AYE
JONES [inaudible]
HEY ALAN.
ALLEN I FORGES CABALLERO
CABALLERO AYE HERTZBERG HUESO
AYE HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY
[inaudible]
MONNING HI.
AS FIVE BUT WE'LL PUT IN CLOSE
FIVE VOTES WE WILL LEAVE IT ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
I THINK SENATOR CAFIERO YOU ARE.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST.
LET'S UPDATE THIS NO SURVEY.
WELCOME THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
US [inaudible]
FOR ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
[inaudible]
THE FARGO.
VERY.
EDGY HERE TO TESTIFY THIS BILL --
I WILL.
OKAY OKAY AREN'T GREAT
[inaudible]
CLOSER CARRIER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN THE AERIAL
SNOW OBSERVATORY.
SINCE NINETEEN TWENTY NINE
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A GLOBAL
LEADER IN SNOW PACK MEASUREMENT
AND MONITORING WHEN THE STATE
BEGAN MEASURING SNOW VOLUMES AT
VARIOUS POINTS IN THIS YEAR IN
ABOUT A MOUNTAINS RUNOFF
FORECAST ALLOWED US TO PLAN AND
BUILD A WORLD CLASS SYSTEM OF
WATER MANAGEMENT INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE CAPTURE CONTROL.
AND DELIVER WATER RELIANT ON
UNDERSTANDING ANNUAL SNOW
ACCUMULATION AND MELTING AT
VARIOUS WATERSHEDS.
AS CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS ARE
COMPARTEN KEATING DEMANDS ON OUR
WATER SUPPLIES ARE CONVENTIONAL
APPROACHES FOR WATER MANAGEMENT
HAVE LEAD TO COSTLY MISTAKES
THAT WE CAN NO LONGER AFFORD TO
MAKE.
WE RELEASE WATER TO MAKE SPACE
FOR FLOODS THAT NEVER COME.
FLOOD TO COME FASTER IN SOONER
THAN EXPECTED WITH LITTLE TIME
TO EVACUATE.
OUT RESERVOIRS AND WE MISS
OPPORTUNITIES TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF EXCESS FLOWS FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT OR GROUND WATER
STORAGE.
SINCE NINETEEN THIRTY SINCE.
TWENTY THIRTEEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES HAS WORKED
WITH THE COALITION OF WATER
USERS ON A NOVEL PILOT PROJECT
TO OBTAIN HIGHLY DETAILED DATA
ABOUT OUR SIERRA SNOW PACK AND
TO CREATE RUN OFF FORECAST. FOR
A SELECT NUMBER OF BASINS IN THE
HIGH SIERRAS.
THIS PROJECT THROUGH THE
AIRBORNE SNOW OBSERVATORY IS AN
AERIAL SNOW MONITORING TOOL THAT
PROVIDES PRECISE MEASUREMENTS OF
SNOW DEPTH FOR EVERY SQUARE
METER OF SNOW IN A WATERSHED.
SB FORTY SEVEN PROPOSES TO
EXPAND THIS PILOT PROJECT TO THE
ENTIRE SIERRA SIERRA NEVADA
MOUNTAINS IN TRINITY ALPS EVERY
MAJOR SNOW COVERED AREA.
THE AS THE SO TECHNOLOGY USES
PLAIN MOUNT MOUNTED LIDAR OR
LIGHT DETECTION AND RANGING TO
MEASURE THE DISTANCE OF OBJECTS
BELOW.
THE PLANE TRAVELS ACROSS THE
WATERSHED TAKING MEASUREMENTS OF
THE TERRAIN AND THE SURVEYS
OCCUR BEFORE THE SNOW HAS FALLEN
IN AGAIN MONTHLY DURING THE
WINTER AND SPRING.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
MEASUREMENTS AND THE SUBSEQUENT
ONES DOES DETERMINES THE SNOW
DEPTH IN THE WATERSHED.
THEN WATER MANAGERS USE THE
MEASUREMENTS TO DEVELOP
ESTIMATES OF HOW MUCH WATER WILL
BE IN STREAMS AND CREEKS RIVERS
AND LAKES IN THE COMING DAYS.
THE MEASUREMENTS FROM A SO ARE
EXTREMELY PRECISE THE RUNOFF
FORECAST USING A SO DATA --
BETWEEN NINETY SIX AND 99%
ACCURATE TRADITIONAL SURVEYS YOU
KNOW WHERE THEY SEND SOME GUY
OUT THERE WITH THAT.
WITH A STICK -- WHICH WHICH ARE
GREAT YOU KNOW [inaudible]
HAVE A HAVE HAVE A MARGIN OF
ERROR OF 4260%.
BECAUSE THE DATA SO SURVEYS
PROVIDE IS SO HIGHLY ACCURATE IT
ELIMINATES THE GUESS WORK OF
RESERVOIR MANAGEMENT AND REDUCES
UNNECESSARY RELEASES EFFECTIVELY
ADDING SURFACE WATER STORAGE
WITHOUT ANY CONSTRUCTION.
IN ADDITION TO WATER SUPPLY AND
FLOOD FORECASTING BENEFIT AS A
ESOS SURVEYS ARE USEFUL FOR
ASSESSING MANY ON THE GROUND
CONDITIONS THAT SUPPORT FOREST
HEALTH.
FIR MANAGEMENT TRANSPORTATION
AND RECREATION ALL THE THINGS
THAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT IN
TERMS OF OUR CLIMATE -- THE BOND
THAT WE WERE WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT EARLIER.
SB FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN PROVIDES
FIFTEEN MILLION FOR SURVEY AND
FORECAST DEVELOPMENT EACH YEAR
OVER A TEN YEAR PERIOD.
IT INCLUDES THE FLIGHT THE DATA
PROCESSING THE MODELING AND TO
DEVELOP OF RUN OFF FORECAST FOR
EVERY MAJOR SIERRA OR A DECENT
BASE AND THE DRAINS INTO A LAKE
A RESERVOIR.
IT IS MANAGE FOR WATER SUPPLY
FLOOD CONTROL OR TO SUPPORT THE
ENVIRONMENT WE BELIEVE THAT TEN
YEARS IS THE MINIMUM AMOUNT OF
TIME NEEDED TO SEE THE FULL
BENEFITS.
OF FOR ALL OF THE BASINS A THIRD
OF THIS YEAR AS HAS ALREADY BEEN
SURVEYED AND TWO THIRDS.
ARE IS PROPOSED TO BE ADDED UP
FOR FULL FUNCTIONALITY WITH D.
W. OURS CURRENT RUNOFF MODELING
AND FORECASTING EFFORTS.
WITH ME HERE TODAY TO PRESENT
TESTIMONY TESTIMONY IS JEFF
PAINTER LOCK IRRIGATION DISTRICT
WATER POLICY DIRECTOR FRANK
KIRKE RETIRED D. W. R. C. SNOW
SURVEY CHIEF AND MARTHA DAVIS
MONO LAKE COMMITTEE BOARD MEMBER.
THANK YOU.
CENTER CARRIER OPENNESS IN
SUPPORT WELCOME FROM THE
MOUNTAINS YOU'RE YOU'RE A LITTLE
WAYS AWAY.
THANK YOU I DO FEEL -- A LITTLE
YLIDES IN AS OPPOSED TO BEING
OUT IN THE FIELD WITH FOLKS LIKE
YOU.
I DO APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK WITH YOU ABOUT THIS THIS
MORNING -- SO SURVEYS WERE
DEVELOPED BY DOCTOR JAMES EACH
CHURCH BEGINNING IN NINETEEN OH
NINE TO MAKE POSSIBLE FORECASTS
OF SUBSEQUENT SPRING RUN OFF.
OUR ABILITY TO FORECAST RUNOFF
HAS MADE FOR MORE EFFICIENT USE
OF EXISTING RESERVOIR CAPACITY.
FOR BOTH WATER SUPPLY FLOOD
CONTROL ENVIRONMENTAL RELEASES
AND HYDROELECTRIC GENERATION.
DURING SUBSEQUENT YEARS
EVOLUTIONARY IMPROVEMENTS WERE
MADE TO IMPROVE THEIR TIMING AND
ACCURACY OF SNOW MEASUREMENTS
AND RUN OFF FOR CASH.
CURRENT OPERATIONAL WATER SUPPLY
FORECASTING RELIES ON THESE
GROUND BASED MEASUREMENTS.
THE EXISTING NETWORK OF SNOW
COURSES AND SNOW SENSORS IS VERY
SPARSE AND CANNOT CAPTURE.
THE TERRAIN AND TURN COLD --
VERY ABILITY OF SNOW
ACCUMULATION AND MELT AND
THEREFORE ARE ONLY AN INDEX OF
THE SHOW IN A GIVEN AREA.
EXISTING RUNOFF FORECASTING
REALIZE EITHER ON A STATISTICAL
LIKE AN INDEX METHOD OR ON A
PHYSICALLY BASED MODEL RELATING
VARIOUS VARIABLES TO THE SPRING
RUN OFF.
THE INDEX METHOD IS ATTRACTIVE
BECAUSE OF ITS RELATIVE
SIMPLICITY BUT IT SUFFERS THE
THREE DIFFICULTIES IT DOESN'T
WORK THAT WELL IN VERY WET OR
VERY DRY CONDITIONS.
AND FURTHER MAKES THE ASSUMPTION
THAT THE CLIMATE IS STATIONARY
AND AGAIN WE KNOW THAT'S
UNSERVED AND PROVE CHAU OUR OUR
FORECASTS ARE INCREASINGLY MORE
DIFFICULT AND LESS ACCURATE THAN
THEY HAD BEEN IN THE PAST.
THE PHYSICALLY BASED MODEL
ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE DEFICIENCIES.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE PRIMARY
DRIVER -- FOR THE SPRING RUN OF
THESE COURSES SNOW PACK AND THE
FOOD THAT WE CANNOT VALIDATE
WITH CURRENT TECHNIQUES THE
COMPUTER VALUE OF THE MODEL.
I'VE BEEN MEASURING SNOW IN
CALIFORNIA FOR NEARLY FORTY
YEARS AND THE AIRBORNE SNOW
OBSERVATORY IS A GAME CHANGER
FOR SNOW PACK MEASUREMENT.
AND THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
DEVELOPMENT IN THE HISTORY OF
SNOW SURVEYS. TO PARAPHRASE A
QUOTE FROM THE MOVIE MEN IN
BLACK BEFORE A A SHOW YOU
THOUGHT YOU KNEW ABOUT THE SNOW
PACK NOW IMAGINE WHAT YOU'LL
KNOW TOMORROW.
IT IS THE FIRST TIME WE'VE HAD
AN ACCURATE MEASUREMENT OF THE
TOTAL VOLUME STILL VOLUME AND
DISTRIBUTION OVER A LARGE AREA.
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT DEFINES A QUANTITY OF
RUN OFF INTO A GIVEN REG FOR
WITH VERY HIGH ACCURACY.
AND ALLOWS WATER MANAGERS MUCH
GREATER FLEXIBILITY IN ADJUSTING
THE QUALITY AT THE TIMING AND
THE QUANTITY OF THEIR RELEASES.
IT IS ALSO NOW POSSIBLE TO
VALIDATE MODELED SNOW PACK
RESULTS AND MAKE IMPROVEMENTS IN
OTHER MODELS FOR EXAMPLE RELATED
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE AIR SO IS MUCH MORE THAN
JUST ABOUT WATER SMELLING FUND
CONTROL.
THE DATA SETS HAVE TREMENDOUS
UTILITY OVER A BROAD RANGE OF
DISCIPLINES INCLUDING HABITAT
STUDIES FIRE SPREAD AND A
SEVERITY.
VEGETATION ANALYSIS SUCH AS TREE
MORTALITY TRANSPORTATION AND
CLIMB AN ANALYSIS THE PROGRAM IS
WORKING -- COLLABORATING WITH
THE U. S. FOR SERVICE AND
NATIONAL PARK SERVICE ALREADY ON
PRE AND POST FIRE -- AN ANALYSIS
FOR THESE WATERSHEDS.
AND I'LL BE HAPPY AT THE END TO
ENSURE A QUESTIONS MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
FOR HEARING US TODAY MY NAME'S
JEFF PAIN I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
WATER POLICY FOR THE FRONT WATER
AUTHORITY -- A SO IS -- JUST
ECHO FRANCE REMARKS HERE VERY
QUICKLY VERY VERY EXCITING
TECHNOLOGY IT'S LIKE GOING FROM
RAIN GAUGES TO RADAR FOR SNOW
MEASUREMENT.
AND I'M SPEAKING HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF A CONSORTIUM OF OUR
USERS IT'S BEEN GROWING I'VE GOT
A BROCHURE HERE THAT I HAVE
COPIES OF THIS PORTION OF THE
HEARING ABOUT IT THAT'S IN
YELLOW HIGHLIGHTED HERE.
IS IT'S FROM THE WALL ME ALL THE
WAY DOWN THE KOREA IS CURRENTLY
BEING SURVEYED THIS YEAR.
AND THAT INCLUDES WATER USERS
THAT ARE BENEFITING FROM THE
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO -- AND
FROM AGRICULTURAL LANDS FROM
MERCED ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
BAKERSFIELD -- THE WATER
MANAGERS SHARE SEVERAL
CHALLENGES IN THIS AREA AND
STATEWIDE -- THEY NEED TO
BALANCE THE RISK OF FLOOD
CONTROL WITH WATER SUPPLY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL NEEDS --
PARTICULARLY ON THE SAN JOAQUIN
FOR THE THE FRIEND VISION WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF RESTORATION
PROGRAM ON SAN JOAQUIN RIVER --
PARTICULAR FOR FRANK DIVISION
WERE LOOKING CONJUNCTIVE
MANAGEMENT AND ARE THE TRYING TO
VISION WAS DEVELOPED TO TAKE
EPISODIC FLOWS OFF OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER.
AND RECHARGE GROUNDWATER AND I
WAS A DESIGN THAT WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN THE NINETEEN
FORTIES.
AND IN ORDER TO DO THAT WE NEED
TO UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH SNOW
THERE IS AND WHEN IT'S RUNNING
OFF.
AND TO DO THAT WITH ADDITIONAL
BURDENS OF YOU KNOW.
SIGMA IMPLEMENTATION -- WITH
RESTORATION AND TRYING TO MANAGE
THAT WATER SUPPLIES WE HAVE FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT MORE EFFECTIVELY.
IT'S CREATING AS A SYSTEM IN
WHICH THE X. EXPENSIVE MISTAKES
OF TAKING A CONSERVATIVE
APPROACH UNDER WATER SUPPLY.
LOSES BIG OPPORTUNITIES.
AND I HAVE A COUPLE OF ANECDOTES
THAT WE'VE ALREADY -- COLLECTED
THROUGH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE LAST SEVEN YEARS THE TALL ME
WAS THE FIRST WATERSHED OUT OF
THE GATE. TO SEE THIS
IMPLEMENTED SO THEY'VE GOT SEVEN
YEARS OF PRACTICE.
THIS TECHNOLOGY'S COMPLETELY
BAKED INTO HOW THEY'RE DOING
WATER MANAGEMENT TODAY.
AND LAST YEAR AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AS SO SAVED A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE FEET
FROM BEING SPILT THEIR WARES AND
ENCOURAGEMENT INTO THE FLOOD
POCKET.
AND THEY WERE BEING ASKED AT
DAWN PETER TO EVACUATE THAT
WATER SENT DOWN THE RIVER AND
MAKE SPACE FOR MORE RAIN.
WITH A SO THEY KNEW HOW MUCH
WATER WAS ON THE GROUND THEY
KNEW THAT THERE'S NO WAY IF IT
ALL MELTED THAT THEY WOULD SPILL
A DROP.
AND THEY COULD SEE THAT THERE
WEREN'T ANY ATMOSPHERE COVERS ON
THE HORIZON THEY WERE COMPELLED
TO SHARE THAT AND THEY WERE ABLE
TO SAVE THAT WATER THAT'S WATER
THAT THAT GOES INTO GROUND WATER
NOW.
AND KEEPS THE VALLEY PRODUCTIVE --
ON THE FRIEND SYSTEM WE INVESTED
IN AND TRYING TO GET A A SO INTO
THE SAN JOAQUIN OUT OF THE
TWELVE AS A FIRST STEP BECAUSE
WE WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
DROUGHT.
AND WE WERE HAVING ALLOCATIONS
THAT WERE 10% BELOW WHAT THEY
ULTIMATELY COULD HAVE BEEN.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT 10% IN A
CRITICAL DROUGHT BECAUSE YOU'RE
FOLLOWING LAND OR YOU'RE DOING
UNNECESSARY GROUNDWATER PUMPING
IN A DRY YEAR WHEN YOU COULD
HAVE HAD THE KNOWLEDGE OF HOW
MUCH SNOW THAT WS ON THE GROUND.
SO THIS IS A TECHNOLOGY THAT DRY.
WHAT YEAR AVERAGE YEAR PRODUCES
OPPORTUNITIES TO MANAGE OUR
WATER RESOURCES A A LOT BETTER --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- I'LL
JUST ADD THAT AID IT ADDS A SOME
CONFIDENCE AND FLOOD MANAGEMENT --
THIS YEAR I WAS JUST SPEAKING
WITH WATER MASS FROM THE KINGS
RIVER.
AND HE WAS SAYING THAT THE THE
NEW SERVICE THAT WE ARE JUST
GETTING OUT OVER EMAIL THIS WEEK
HAVE GIVEN HIM THE CONFIDENCE TO
BE ABLE TO RELEASE FLOOD CONTROL
IN A MORE MODERATED -- MANNER
RIGHT NOW SO HE'S MAKING
ADDITIONAL RELEASES WITH THE
CONFIDENCE THAT THE RESERVOIR
WILL REFUND LATER AND THAT THIS
IS GOING TO AVOID A SURPRISE
LATER IN THE SEASON.
AND THE SURPRISES ARE EXPENSIVE
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT BECAUSE YOU
END UP WITH THESE MODULATED
POLLS FLOWS THAT ARE ARE
SOMETIMES DESTRUCTIVE TO HABITAT
YOU'RE TRYING. TO TO RESTORE
THANK YOU.
THANKS SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR INVITING
ME TO SPEAK TODAY THE DAVIS
BOARD MEMBER FOR THE MONO LAKE
COMMITTEE IN THE VERY LONG
DISTANT PAST.
IT WAS ALSO THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR.
BUT WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT IN
CONCEPT ON THIS BILL WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS ON SOME MINOR TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY SOME OF
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL.
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE EXPLAINED THE
TECHNOLOGY I THINK VERY WELL IN
MANY OF THE USES.
SO.
I JUST WANT TO TESTIFY AS A USER
OF THE STATE -- WE WILL MODEL
LIKE COMMITTEE WAS INCLUDED VERY
EARLY ON AS PART OF TESTING THE
DATA AND ITS ACCURACY.
AND IN ONE WORD THIS TECHNOLOGY
IS TRANSFORMATIONAL.
IT IS INCREDIBLY ACCURATE BUT
PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF IT IS FIGURING OUT THE
TIMING OF WHEN THE WATER IS
COMING DOWN.
SO WE CAN PROACTIVELY MANAGE FOR
MULTIPLE PURPOSES SO IT IS WATER
MANAGEMENT BUT IT'S ALSO
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT ITS
ECOSYSTEM PROTECTION RESTORATION
WERE USING AT ALL AND THAT'S
THAT OUR EXPERIENCE WITH IN THE
MONO BASIN.
I THINK AS WE LOOK TO THE FUTURE
ONE WILL UNDERSCORE THE
IMPORTANCE OF NOT ONLY MAKING
THE SUMMARY OF THE DATA
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC BUT THE
DATA ITSELF.
SO IT SHOULD BE CONSISTENT WITH
THE PROVISIONS OF AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY FIVE AS WE LOOK AT THIS
DATA.
THIS IS THE FOUNDATIONAL DATA
FOR ADAPTATION TO CLIMATE CHANGE
WE CAN'T MANAGE WHAT WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
AND THIS DATA PROVIDES AS CLOSE
TO REAL TIME WATER DATA UP AND
DOWN THE STAIRS TO REALLY FIGURE
OUT HOW TO MANAGE NOT JUST FOR
WATER AND RESOURCES BUT ACROSS
THE BREADTH.
OF RESOURCE ISSUES THAT ARE
COMMUNITIES ARE FACING -- WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HOW DID INTRODUCED AND
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MORNING MR CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE WHEN THE RIVER BUSH
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES ARE
AQUA IT'S FANTASTIC TO SEE
PROACTIVE WATER DISTRICTS.
REALLY TRYING TO BETTER MANAGE --
THE SUPPLY AND WE ALWAYS TALK
ABOUT ALL THE TOOLS IN THE
TOOLBOX WATER CONSERVATION
RECYCLING EXCEPT TRACK.
THIS IS ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE
VERY IMPORTANT TOOLS IN THE
TOOLBOX THANK.
ADAM ROBIN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GARY LANGER DUCKS UNLIMITED WE
ARE A WETLANDS BASED
ORGANIZATION OVER HALF OF OUR
STAFF OR WEAPONS BIOLOGISTS
WE'VE FUND WITHOUT WATER WE
DON'T HAVE WETLANDS NERD WITH
WATER FILE.
PRINT CHIU SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING JOSH WEIMER WITH
THE TURLOCK IRRIGATION DISTRICT
AND STRONG SUPPORTER AND WE
REALLY THINK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CANDIDATE JOGO WITH WALK
A GROUP ON BEHALF THE MODESTO
IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND THE
KINGS RIVER WATER CESSATION ALSO
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THING OTHERS IN SUPPORT THOSE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE MEMBERS QUESTIONS
COME.
RUNNING [inaudible]
THERE JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD CLEARLY.
THE OBJECTIVES ARE SOUND IN MY
QUESTION JUST GOES TO THE IN THE
ANALYSIS.
IT SEEKING.
A COMMITMENT OF FUNDING FOR OVER
TEN YEARS -- IN IT LOOKS LIKE IT
PENCILS OUT FIFTEEN MILLION A
YEAR FOR TEN YEARS.
DO YOU KNOW OFFHAND WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THAT WOULD BE PART
OF THE CONTRACT WITH NASA OR
WHOEVER'S DOING THE THE AERIAL
SURVEILLANCE.
WELL MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THE THAT CURRENTLY WITH WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS ALL OF THAT -- WELL
I WOULD EXPECT THAT IT WILL.
ALL OF IT WOULD WOULD COME FROM
ALL OF IT WOULD BE PART OF THE
CONTRACT BUT MAYBE.
MAYBE WITH THE EXPERIENCE OF THE
CURRENT CONTRACT WE CAN.
THE MAJORITY THE COST WOULD BE
FOR THE AERIAL SURVEYS THAT
WHICH COULD BE CONDUCTED BY AT
NASA OR A PRIVATE CONTRACTOR.
IN ITS ITS ADMINISTERED THROUGH
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES IS
THAT CORRECT IN SO THERE'S THE
TRANSPARENCY OF THE DATA --
GOING UP AND I THINK FOR
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OF A
COMMITMENT OF THE TEN YEAR
FUNDING -- WHAT'S THE
TRANSPARENCY ON HOW THE MONEY IS
ACTUALLY SPENT.
IN TERMS OF THOSE CONTRACTS WITH
NASA I ASSUME OR YES I'D LIKE
RECORD.
COM I WOULD I WOULD EXPECT WE'D
HAVE FULL TRANSPARENCY IF THAT'S
NOT CLEAR IN THE BILL WE CAN
MAKE IT.
WE CAN MAKE THAT CLEAR IN
ADDITION TO ANY -- OVERHEAD THAT
MIGHT BE.
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO LIMIT THE
OVERHEAD TO AND I I ALSO WANT TO
JUST BE UNDERSTOOD I UNDERSTAND
THE BENEFIT OFTEN OF LONG TERM.
COMMITMENT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CONTRACTING AND THAT HOPE IF
THIS COMMITMENT IS MADE BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
HE COULD ALSO RESULT IN PERHAPS
SOME MORE NEGOTIATING LEVERAGE
WITH NASSER WHOEVER THE
CONTRACTOR IS -- TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THAT LONGER TERM COMMITMENT
IN A SINGLE BUDGET YEAR.
YOU RAISE A GOOD POINT I MY
UNDERSTANDING.
FROM.
FROM PAST WORK THAT I'VE DONE IS
THAT -- NASA -- DOES SIGNIFICANT
AERIAL.
ANALYSIS -- RESEARCH AND
ANALYSIS NOT ONLY ON SNOW PACK
BUT ALSO IN VEGETATION --
PARTICULARLY AS THEY'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THE DEAD AND DYING
TREES -- THEY HAVE SIGNIFICANT
MAPPING AND SO I I THINK THERE'S
PROBABLY ECONOMIES OF SCALE
THERE.
BUT AT LEAST FOR THIS PURPOSE
WE'VE PUT IT AB APPROXIMATE
AMOUNT BASED ON THE PAST
CONTRACTS AND I I DO EXPECT THAT
THERE WOULD BE EFFICIENCIES AT
SOME POINT BUT THANK YOU AGAIN I
AM SUPPORTIVE TODAY I WOULD ALSO
THINK.
IF NECESSARY BOB MAYBE WE
APPROACH OUR FEDERAL
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION SEE IF
THEY WANNA CHIP INTO THIS
IMPORTANT EFFORT AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SIR MONNING VICE CHAIR WELL
ON ON THAT NOTE RIGHT INTO
QUESTIONS ONE FOR THE OTHER ONE
FOR FRANK -- ON THE FUNDING HAVE
YOU CONSIDERED LOOKING AT CAP
AND TRADE DOLLARS RATHER THAN
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS.
HI A WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
DIFFERENT FUNDING SOURCES -- AND
FRANKLY THAT'S A DISCUSSION WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN TERMS
OF WHERE THE RESOURCES MIGHT BE
BEST.
I THINK THAT MIGHT HAVE
SOMETHING A LOOKING INTO AS WELL
THEN ON FRANK YOU MENTION A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLES WHERE THIS
HAS ALREADY BEEN HELPFUL.
WHAT -- HOW MANY YEARS AND HAVE
YOU BEEN OR HAS THIS BEEN USED
IN THE AREAS IT'S ALREADY BEING
USED?
A GOOD QUESTION IT'S BEEN IT'S
BEEN A RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
EFFORT FOR AT LEAST SEVEN YEARS
IT WAS STARTED IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN WITH OUR FIRST WINTER
SURVEYS.
AND SO THE TWO WITH ONLY THIS
PHONE ME AND BEGINNING -- THIS
WILL BE THE THIRD YEAR FOR THE
SAN JOAQUIN SYSTEM AND SO IT'S
THIS YEAR THAT WE'RE JUST
STARTING TO GET THE MODELS.
UP AND RUNNING FROM THE THE
SERVICE AND THE EXPERIENCE SO
FAR HAS BEEN THAT THE MODELS
THAT THE THAT THE ANALYSIS
PREDICTS ACTUALLY.
AT AND THEY'RE PLAYING OUT.
VERY CLOSER EXACTLY HOW THE
MODEL SAYS ARE GONNA.
GO AT THE THE THE QUANTITY OF
SNOW THAT IS IS CAPTURED ON THE
GROUND IS THE 96298% SO THE
TOTAL RUNOFF FOR THE YEAR IN
APRIL CAN BE.
ESTIMATED ON APRIL FIRST.
AS LONG AS YOU'RE NEGLECTING
FUTURE RAINFALL MUTE YOU'LL
NEVER GET THAT CRITICAL.
WHAT INSPIRED MY QUESTIONS YOU
SAID THAT THE THE -- AN ACT AND
I'M SUPPORTING THE BILL AND I
I'M JUST TRYING TO GET US SOME
MORE BACKGROUND ON IT I GUESS.
THE THE KERN RIVER I'VE MANAGER
YOU SAID IS.
HOLDING BACK A RELEASE BASED ON
THE ANALYSIS THAT HE'S RECEIVING
RIGHT NOW SO.
NOT THAT EXAMPLE BUT ARE THERE
OTHER EXAMPLES WHERE THEY WERE
SOMEBODY MADE A DECISION.
AND THE MODELING WAS INACCURATE
I GUESS IS KIND OF WHERE I'M
GOING WITH THIS.
YEAH I I MEAN I THINK THE
EXAMPLE -- THAT THAT WE SAW ON
THE THE TALL ME IS THE MOST
INSTRUCTIVE BECAUSE THEY THEY'RE
BEING TOLD BY FLOOD CONTROL
CURBS SO FLOOD CONTROL CURVE IS
SORT OF AN ENGINEERS
APPROXIMATION OF YOUR RISK OF
FUTURE RAINFALL.
AND THE RISK OF FUTURE SNOW
MALCOLM OCCURRING SIMULTANEOUSLY
AND THEN OVERTOPPING YOUR
RESERVOIR.
SO THEY'VE GOT A STATISTICAL
MODEL BUT IF YOU CAN ACTUALLY.
COUNT ALL THE WATER MOLECULES ON
THE GROUND.
ON EVERY SQUARE METER OF EARTH
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT THERE'S NO
ATMOSPHERIC RIVER COMING.
THEN YOU KNOW WHAT YOUR RISK IS
THERE'S NO MORE STATISTICAL
GUESSWORK.
AND SO IS THE STATISTICAL
ADVANCE FOR QUESTIONS AT THAT
YEAH NO I THINK YOU DID AND
THAT'S THAT'S REALLY INTERESTING
THAT THAT IS ONE THE REASONS WHY
I'M SUPPORTING IT BECAUSE IT'S
THE ACCURACY SEEMS TO BE.
RIGHT ON SPOT SO -- THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD IN.
I MEAN TO OUR EARLIER
CONVERSATION TRYING.
TO I GUESS GET THE DATA PART OF
THIS PUZZLE SORTED OUT IN A MORE
ACCURATE WAYS WE CAN ACTUALLY
SCOPE [inaudible]
THE NEED.
DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT
[inaudible]
SAVINGS THIS KIND OF THE ACT TO
INCREASE ACCURACY COULD YIELD DO
YOU HAVE ANY I MEAN YOU MENTION
A 10%.
SORT OF FALL SHORTFALL IN OTHER
WORDS THAT WAS.
BUILT IN BUT ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WAYS TO PUT TOGETHER ESTIMATES
HERE [inaudible]
SORT OF COST OVER TIME -- I OVER
TIME.
I MEAN THERE'S AVOIDED COSTS FOR
FLOOD RISK WHICH I I MEAN ARE
VERY DIFFICULT TO ESTIMATE I
MEAN THE WHOLE SNOW SURVEY
PROGRAM.
WAS BUILT ON RESOLVING FLOOD
RISK RIGHT SO -- BUT THE
ADDITIONAL COSTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES THAT YOU WOULD FOR
GONE IS THE WAY THAT I WOULD
CALCULATE IT FOR A A WATER
MANAGEMENT ENTITY SO A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE FEET.
ON ON THE TWELVE MAY I MEAN
WHAT'S WHAT'S THAT WORTH WHAT'S
THAT WORTH IN A DRY YEAR --
THAT'S THAT'S THE VALUE THAT
WE'RE JUST GETTING AND YOU CAN
GET THOSE PULSES.
JUST EVERY SINGLE YEAR WHAT IS
IT WITH AND I I'D I'M NOT
CERTAIN BUT THAT WOULD BE FOR
THE ENTIRE STATE WE HAVE NOT
ESTIMATED THAT [inaudible]
I KNOW.
YEAH MOTION ON THE BILL -- WE'LL
KEEP MOVING THIS ALONG -- THIS
IS THE PROPER APPROPRIATIONS
GONNA DIVE SEE DRILL DEEPER IN
THE COST AND SOME IS GONNA BE A
FUNCTION OF GOVERNOR'S
PRIORITIES DID DID OF YOURS
PRIORITIES.
WHAT HAPPENS IN CONGRESS
HOPEFULLY THEY STAB GUIDING THE
BUDGET ON DOING JUST BASIC
SCIENCE RESEARCH THAT I KEEP
HEARING MORE AND MORE ABOUT?
CUTTING CUTTING CUTTING AROUND
MONITORING IN BASIC -- SATELLITE
DATA SO THAT'S A PROBLEM BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE BEFORE THIS
HITS THE FLOOR TO PAY OUT
BECAUSE IN APPROPRIATIONS JUST A
BETTER SENSE OF YOU KNOW WE MAKE
A CONTINUOUS PREPARATION FOR A
DECADE THAT'S A BIG.
THAT'S A BIG GIVE SO EXACTLY
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO BE GETTING
FOR OUR MONEY OVER TIME AND I
THINK THERE'S A CASE TO MAKE
HERE ABOUT IT.
AS A SORT OF SAVINGS BASED
INVESTMENT AGAIN BUT I'D LOVE
MORE DETAIL ON THAT AS WE GO ON
BY THE WAY NOT JUST IN THE
AGRICULTURAL SIDE BUT YOU LOOK
AT THE POWER SIDE OF THINGS AND
IF WE DON'T KNOW WHAT ARE FLOWS
ARE GOING TO BE HYDRO POWER.
WE DON'T KNOW -- WHAT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE WE MAY HAVE TO FIRE
UP GAS PLANTS OR IMPORT POWER
FROM OUT OF STATE SO?
THIS ALL MATTERS ANY HOW WE DO
HAVE A MOTION -- BUT ARE YOU UP
FOR SORT OF A DEEPER DIVE THERE
AND JUST KEEP WORKING WITH US ON
THAT HE'S OKAY SELECT EVERY
GREAT THANK YOU -- YOU CAN MAKE
YOUR CLOTHES IF YOU'D LIKE.
COM THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
ROBUST BRO BUS DISCUSSION WE'VE
TAKEN NOTES ON ON THINGS TO
FOLLOW UP ON I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS GIVES US -- COULD SCIENCE
DATA UPON WHICH WE CAN BOMB.
PROTECT NOT ONLY ARE RISK OUR
FLOOD CONTROL RISK BUT ALSO THE
OPPORTUNITY BE ABLE TO USE THIS
WATER IN A WAY THAT'S MUCH MORE
PRODUCTIVE AND YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE COST.
IF YOU KNOW IF YOU REALLY GET
INTO IT YOU CAN LOOK AT THE COST
OF RELEASING WATER -- AHEAD OF
TIME AND NOT USING IT IN A WAY
THAT'S THE MOST PRODUCTIVE
EITHER -- TO TAKE CARE FAMILIES
OR TO TO GROW OUR OUR PRODUCE
AND SO THIS GIVES US DATA TO BE
ABLE TO TO MEET MEET AS MANY
NEEDS AS POSSIBLE AND AS WE'RE
ASKING PEOPLE TO CONSERVE WE
ALSO NEED. TO CONSERVE OUR
STORAGE.
WELL THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATE
STERN STERN AYE JONES.
JONES I ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE A BARGES CABALLERO
CABALLERO AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HIGHWAY SO HUESO AYE
JACKSON MONEY MONEY.
NINE THAT HAS SUFFICIENT ROSE
BUT LEAVING OPEN THAT IS
SUFFICIENT VOTES -- WE WILL
LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR ONE MORE.
SENATE JACKSON TO MORE -- THANK
YOU BOTH.
I SEE OKAY WELL -- SO CENTER
JACKSON PRESENTING.
SU HANG TIGHT.
YEAH HEY HURTS
.
EASY FOR YOU -- TO SO WE ARE
GOING TO OPEN THE RULES ON THE
MEASURES OUTSTANDING -- FIRST
OFF WE HAVE SENATE BILL FORTY
FIVE THE CURRENT VOTED SIX TO
ONE CHAIR VOTING HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR SENATOR
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
SENATORS BURGESS [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE.
OKAY -- IT WILL CLOSE ROLE THAT --%
SEVEN ONE FILING A MEMBER TO BE
TWO SIXTY TWO MCGUIRE CARVER TO
SIX TO ONE TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING I'D
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CENTER
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE JACKSON SENT SEVEN
NO ONE WILL PUT THAT.
MEASURE ON CALL WHEN WAIT FOR
THAT STANDING MEMBER.
SENATE OF FILING FOR SB THREE
SIXTY SEVEN HUESO CURRENT VOTE
IS FIVE ZERO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATORS PORGES.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I'D JACKSON
WITH SIX ZERO SIX TWO ZERO THAT
IS VISION VOTES WILL LEAVE IT ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBER.
MOVING ALONG AS BEFORE -- FOR
CENTER CHIANG KERR Và SEVEN
ZERO CHAIR VOTING I DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SENATE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG I'D JACKSON EIGHT ZERO
EIGHT ZERO WE WILL LEAVE THAT
MEASURE ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBER FINALLY FILE ITEM SEVEN
IS BEFORE EIGHTY SEVEN COMING
YEAR SEVEN ZERO DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING ON A
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS BURGESS.
JACKSON BURGESS AYE JACKSON OKAY
SO.
EIGHT ZERO OKAY WE LEAVE THE
MEASURE ON CALL
.
SO EAT YOU'VE GOT FOR ITEMS THAT
YOU HAVE NOT VOTED ON ITEM
[inaudible]
YOU'RE A DAVID I WANT SEE TWO
FOUR SIX AND SEVEN OR WATER
COMING YOUR WAY HERE SO.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO IS SB TWO
SIXTY TWO THE CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN A ONE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CHAIRMAN.
YES SURE VOTING CHAIR VOTING I'D
SENATE JACKSON JACKSON HI BILLS
OUT EIGHT THE BILL IS A EIGHT TO
ONE WILL CLOSE ROLE THERE.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB THREE SIX
SEVEN HUESO MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE.
SENATE JACKSON.
YES YES JACKSON I BILLS OF SEVEN
YES THAT BILLS AT SEVEN ZERO
WILL CLOSE ROLE THERE -- SB FOUR
OH FOUR CHIANG.
THE MOTION WAS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THAT
FILE AND REMEMBER SIX IN THE
CURRENT VOTERS -- EIGHT ZERO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CENTER
JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE THE VOTE THERE'S
NINE ZERO AND FINALLY ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB FOUR EIGHTY
SEVEN CABALLERO.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT
VOTERS.
EIGHT ZERO SENATOR JACKSON
JACKSON AYE JERRY GOOD NINE ZERO
THAT BILLS OUT AND WITH THAT WE
ARE ADJOURNED